Four three,
two,
one style band.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Salute sir.
Congratulations man.
Thank you.
You fight your fight.
Friday night was um,
that was what you would call like
a coming out party in America.
In America.
America.
Yeah.
People got to see
first fight in Vegas,
first main event,
a first top 10 guy.
And I feel like I got to kind of like
shut a lot of people up because before
that fight,
a lot of people kind of like,
shit,
it's too much.
It's too soon.
Like the hype.
Yeah.
He's like,
oh he's this and that.
And for me,
I wouldn't take salt to
it cause they don't know.
You know,
you can't,
um,
you can't fault them for it.
So.
Well,
you did a smart thing in
the way you handled your,
your transition to MMA too.
I mean,
you really,
you really took your
time and did it right.
You and I talked for the
first time about this,
how many years ago?
2015 I think you hit me
up on Instagram and said,
you know,
when am I going to call
one of your fights?
And I was like yeah,
we'll take our time.
Cause he's my coach.
He's the mastermind behind all this.
Eugene Bearman without him,
my career will be in the shitter.
So he kinda let just take out time.
There's no rush.
Smart way on 100% cause you see like
looking for a fight guys like example sage
Northcutt he's being up and down in the
UFC fighting or like his rise and stuff
like that.
But you have to,
you can't just come in here with like
maybe three fights on let's maybe like a
Micky gall who also has extensive
background in something else like Jujitsu.
But yeah I took my time for the round
the world for different body types,
different styles.
And then eventually I
think that UFC would like,
okay,
what do you want?
Come on,
let's go.
You built up a lot of hype outside.
You built up some hype kickboxing,
you built up some hype and MMA but
you built up a lot of internet hype.
There was a lot of highlight videos
made to you and people are like,
Oh shit,
look at this guy.
And then dudes were breaking down your,
your videos like breaking down technique.
Like look how he sets this up.
There was one that was it,
Brendan Dorman,
who did it recently?
Was it a Lawrence Ken Chenault?
Maybe it was Brendan Doormen.
The Solara yesterday.
Yeah,
Brendan Doorman.
He did one where you sat that
dude up and then left high,
kicked him.
Uh Oh no,
that was a lot of attention
to those guys are so important
about that kick.
We're drilling it.
I hate you didn't taught it to me,
that setup probably seven days before.
And he said if this lands is the finisher,
he said that why whatever.
And then in the fight something happened
and I didn't even think about it.
Just boom and Atlanta and
I hurt my foot on his head.
Actually I actually hurt me cause
I was a third fight of the night.
So it was a tournament to the final flight
and I hurt my foot in his hand and I
was like okay cause you kind
of see me limping a little bit.
Then I went in on him and just,
yeah I finished it off.
That was a beautiful high tech man.
The way he set it up.
It's so interesting too because you forced
him into this weird battle of erratic
movement like you,
you did a lot of this with them.
You got to take care of this first.
A lot of guys think
like what's for a hobby?
Well he said,
yeah,
take care of this.
Scramble your to it for Asa.
Hobbies,
a treasure.
100%.
He's a treasure.
I liked the way he thinks and then
listen to that podcast and yeah,
when he said that I
was like that's what I,
that's what we do.
I like to make these guys
second guess themselves.
Like just get stuck.
Locate.
He's right here.
Like fuck,
I've got to reset right here.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
Just called Jab and then they just get
flustered and they can talk all this
stuff.
All we're going to do
this and this and that.
Right.
And it's different when you see it on TV,
but when you're in,
cause I've had it done to me.
I've got teammates that
do it to me all the time.
If I'm not on my game,
they do it to me.
And I'm like,
so this is what it feels like.
I don't want to be on
the other side of that.
So if you come in overtrain yeah,
or just say,
Hey,
my day like that Volcker
would catch me on some days.
Dan Oak is a beast,
my guy,
but he's,
it's been like out of three weeks.
Shane young in Singapore,
uh,
myself,
Friday night and Dan Hook her on Saturday.
Dan hookers,
one of them never,
never celebrated in the octagon guy.
He's all,
and even that called them,
I called them Fujita remembering,
was it two one night he looked at you,
he told me it didn't mean to,
but it looked at,
he was like,
do you know who I am now?
And through his mouth guard at the cage,
but he said it went through the cage
and hit her in the chest or something.
It was,
yeah,
it was.
I am now because I knew who he was.
Of course you did,
but like,
it's kind of like the
UFC wasn't really like,
you know,
putting them out there.
They kind of like your sleeping on him.
So he just,
he felt frustrated.
Yeah.
That's just cause he's so ambitious.
Yeah,
100% I don't have men handle with that.
of course.
I know third party,
but all I had him go down and call fights.
Me and him go at it.
Me,
Carlos,
me,
John Vaccae,
Bj plan.
Like so many people don't know yet.
I've told them like
when Kay Warren was the,
the,
the pinnacle of Combat Sports,
right?
New Zealand Australasia was on top of,
you had raised that from Mark Hunt,
Doug Viney,
Jason Weimar more Jordan and guys from
that side of the world like running,
like running it and other
sides of the words as well.
But I felt like we fell off and then New
Zealand coming back and forth kind of
took a little law for a few years,
a long time.
And now it's,
we're doing it again like guys like me,
Dan,
Shane Chi.
We're about to like take it to
the next level and then bring,
bring ends at sports again all the way up.
Well,
you know what's interesting is
that New Zealand in particular,
like you guys,
there's,
there's something about having you guys
come over here and there's not like a
long history where people think of,
you know,
like zoo New Zealand MMA fighters,
but New Zealand kickboxers I mean it's
one of the most rich environments,
like think about all the different high
level kickboxers that came out of New
Zealand or Australia for that matter.
Australasia and general crazy,
crazy number of like really
high level kickboxers.
Like when I came to help a rumble,
uh,
with his camp for Jon Jones because I,
Rashad linked it up and said,
you should come help us out.
And I said,
yeah,
sure.
So it's a black ceilings
when it was still around.
And I was surprised,
I was like,
man,
a standup in America is not,
not even close on.
I love the grappling,
the wrestling,
cause you guys are having in schools
and other presidents come here and open
schools and stuff like that.
But the standup was not on our level.
So I told Eugene that and he's like,
good,
I wanted you to know that because had
the same thing when he went to Vegas and
then he saw like,
man,
these guys,
their standups not really on our level.
So we've always had that.
Um,
I don't know where it comes from.
These like a whole lineage of it.
They've been raised.
Sephora,
we come from the same school.
Sure.
Yeah.
Blg School.
But yeah,
a grappling and stuff.
I feel like we were
behind that first because,
you know,
Internet,
uh,
we get seminars and shit like that and
I've got obsessive trainers like Adam
Johnson,
he's a,
he's my Jujitsu coach in a
way and he's just obsessed.
So they constantly like
upgrading everything.
And I think it went from,
I didn't really get to use my Jujitsu
much a little bit in that fight,
but he,
the take down defense,
that's all Andre as well,
my wrestling coach,
he's a Romanian guy,
so we're,
we don't need to like go anywhere else.
I felt like we've,
we've,
we've got people where we are with
stacked enough to be able to level up and
compete with the rest of the world.
You've got someone like Dan Hooker in
your camp just out of luck when you have
guys like you and him together.
That's what forces everybody to the
next level and everyone's in town do,
you will rise up to,
they'll see what you're doing.
They'll see your fight with Tavarez,
the CCM,
your fights online.
You'll see you in the gym and you when
you have a guy like that in the gym,
I've always experienced this
in Jujitsu and everything else.
Everybody else's level rises up to try
to catch up to that guy percent because
all they see like you guys are at what
the world sees is just us on TV and then
they see like the highlights,
the cool stuff.
But my teammates get to see
me fuck up all the time.
They see me get my licks of course.
So when they see all that stuff,
then they see me on the world
stage kicking ass and like,
man,
of course I can do,
it's like Brad,
Brad Riddell bad as
kickbox a world champion,
one of my teammates or angry panda.
But he's,
yeah,
he's moving,
making this move to MMA now,
right now.
But,
um,
he's,
he's another one of those guys that he
kickbox and doesn't really do it for him.
He's,
he's like built like a
Chad Mendez type guy,
short,
stocky,
pretty thick.
And he could wrestle,
you know,
but no one knows it yet.
So whenever he comes into MMA or UFC,
then everyone's going to be like,
it would take him down.
Let's see what can happen.
But yeah,
they have,
they find out eventually if there's guys
from that section of the world and when
you really stop and think about between
now between New Zealand and Australia,
how many worldclass kickboxers Holy Shit.
A lot.
Yeah.
And they've run through,
not just from this Arab,
but even back in the day.
Right.
But Dennis,
Alexia,
right.
It wasn't right for me with
kickboxing from Hawaii.
I know,
I know.
um,
like say up to ray,
Seth was days like my comp.
I never really invested
in k one back in the day.
I just got to think it guy.
I think Stan longe Anitas was
from Australia by not like this.
There's a deep rooted history and
kickboxing and Australia and that kind of
stuff.
Why,
what happened there?
How'd that get started?
Yeah,
that's a great,
I could sit there if you
want to speak to someone,
usually would be the guy or
told you they're the guys
that have the history just
up here.
But for me I just came in and I
enjoyed it and I jumped in the pool.
Well from the United States you have,
there are some big kickbox camps,
but also you get a lot of guys who've
come here from Holland and from other
kickboxing rich places
and to removed right now.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
And of course guys who fought over there
and came over here like Alister and
guys who entered into MMA.
It's just,
it is interesting that,
you know,
for MMA gyms there's like a certain
level of striking and then you see like a
Nicky hold skin will come and start
training with those guys and you realize
like I was watching it.
Yeah.
A little bit of the spine.
He's good.
What's happening to him now?
Obviously I'm in a while.
I think he's boxing now.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
I think he's decided that there's
more money in boxing and um,
you know,
he's winning some hands as well.
He does got a nasty left hook body route.
Yeah.
Like a stop.
Well,
I think kickbox and like
if I wanted to take the,
the boxing blueprint,
I could have done that because
I'm six and one in boxing as well.
So I could have done that and
just got built up quite like,
you know,
the cans fight,
some champions,
local champions,
some national champions and
eventually on the world stage.
But for me it just,
I never wanted to feel vulnerable.
I never wanted to feel like another guy
could kick my ass into another dislike.
You know Floyd Mayweather,
they about to do this fight with McGregor
part too and they had all these stupid
rules like,
okay.
No,
I think that was all fake.
Yeah,
I know.
But like even the idea of it,
I'm like,
if you're going to do it,
just jump in.
What do we do is okay,
what you,
you're a man like,
Yo,
fuck you.
We're going to do it man to man.
But no kicks.
Don't know kicks.
Don't,
no,
no knees,
no elbows.
And I had that like,
it's just,
I don't understand.
I'm like,
why?
If you want to prove
you're the best fighter,
you have to fight people from other codes.
And this is at the UFC.
That's the highest level,
you know.
So I entered into any wrestling
competition or Jujitsu
graffiting competition.
I have place I,
let me see.
Yes,
a mission.
I never,
I've never been first,
but I'm like either second,
third,
or somewhere else.
But yeah,
I believe it done maybe
four or five of my career.
You have a specialty and I,
I've always felt like
guys who have a specialty,
if they can get to a certain amount
of good at this other thing without
abandoning their skills as a specialty,
are we going to have that giant advantage?
I agree.
And that's just the same thing.
Whatever got them to what they're
good at and they say boxing,
wrestling,
they can do the same thing.
Gary Tonin was a fight.
He um,
he had a one FC or one championship and
not the guy with the one too that wasn't
a Jujitsu stopped punch.
That wasn't like a amateur,
like a guy who's never strike a strike
before he actually looked like he was
flowing well with a stand
up and that's cause he,
same thing happens in Jujitsu or whatever,
you know,
whatever.
It made them great at grappling can
make them great at standup as well.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean obviously there's the added element
of getting hit that some people can't
psychologically handle as well.
We know that was,
yeah,
it makes a big difference.
I used to be but then event like
not if my watch my fight after I,
after it happened,
I look,
I keep looking at what's happening.
I'm,
I'm searching for people,
I'm searching for shots or whatever,
but a lot of people kind
of like either flare,
um,
close up or they not turn away but like
they just try to use the wall and you
can't really use that in
an MMA because the gloves,
they don't help but in kickbox and you
can just like I saw you were there and
numb la when I fought them
for the glory world title.
Yes.
That kind of style.
Like you can just jog and not down
and beat the legs or whatever.
Exactly.
A big gloves.
You can still find your ways around them.
And they made this,
the ring was probably,
if you put three of these tables together,
that was the ring.
It was a smaller group you in.
I cry,
I cracked the code.
I was able to get my
foot work around them.
Even this cage was big enough
for people and that was the case.
Smaller.
I was like,
yeah,
but it was big enough for me to think
about that palms cage that I really like
is I feel,
it feels like it's the right size.
I feel like the set up,
I feel like the you regular
UFC cage is big and I liked it.
It's big,
but it might be too big.
Don't need to be made from,
it was,
it was small but it wasn't like,
oh my God.
Yeah,
like on the phone before.
I mean it looked like he had massive
Matt a lot better than the kickboxing,
right?
Yeah,
I was thinking about that.
It's very rare you get a boxing ring that
has anywhere near the kind of distance
from corner to corner.
Yeah.
Do you a good,
but the UFC,
there's,
there's some pros and cons I think,
but it's a con when it's a fight
like in Ghana versus Derek,
that's when it's a Chi.
Have a video of me before that fight,
like he's yelling.
Somebody got to die,
dude come and they find it.
When I saw Francis wait two 53 I was like,
oh shit.
He's normally jacked.
He looks at it.
He looked,
he looked like he took
it very fucking serious.
I thought he was going to
realize that he got out,
wrestled and now conditioned he's going
to come back guns blazing and tried to
put a beating on Derrick Lewis.
But he was so tentative,
even with a fight like Stephen Wonderboy
Thompson and I'm there until that five
people were like,
it was born.
And I was like,
hell no.
Like I enjoy that fight.
It was just small margin for
error to standup guys who,
you know,
you can understand the game where
it's like the foot placement,
you know,
faints,
all that kind of shit.
And then people were like,
that sucked.
I was like,
well you don't understand,
you know,
striking on that level.
But that Derrick Lewis
flight and for instance,
it was like I tried and
just of it was just,
yeah,
it was gone.
It was the number two least amount of
strikes when ever in a three round fight.
And they're both beasts.
They both,
I know like motherfuckers,
boy,
they both been in crazy fights.
Like they both been in
nothing but exciting fights.
Yeah,
except for you know,
some brief moments.
So it's just a
psychological issue I guess.
Who knows the same.
They said it was too,
like he,
if he had like a PTSD from his last fight,
like shit,
I didn't want to like get
hurt again or whatever.
But he took a beating in
that last fight as well.
He did.
People don't realize he did.
He got fucked up and
that fight five rounds.
What people don't see is how he
felt after it's six hours later,
10 hours later,
24 hours later when his head's pounding.
Headaches got to close
all the drapes and yeah,
no light.
It's alive,
Huh?
Yeah.
I may want to be a fighter.
He's only been doing it for five years.
That's what's really crazy.
And that's the thing,
cause he's just looked at him.
I'm the runt of my people.
You go to Nigeria,
there's literally picks of the
litter when I went back there,
I'm like,
should not be playing football.
Big money in it.
But I think like MMA as like you can
just grab any of those kids and give him
some boxing gloves.
Showed him how to sprawl show
no matter how to wrestle.
And they are beasts like
it's hand in Ganas 10.
Jon Jones is just walking down the street.
I'm the,
I have the same size head
and I was just a skinny boy,
so I looked like a lollipop.
I was a wrong bro.
Honestly,
just the runt of the litter by to work.
I had to develop,
I think maybe like around 15,
I started to get taller.
So every time I come back from school
or from a holiday after school was right
there,
you got to call her.
I ain't got taller.
And then somehow I just filled it out,
realize I go athleticism.
And then later on,
like I was never the athletic kid
playing basketball or anything like that.
I was just the,
the runt.
When did you get into martial arts?
I started in taekwondo when I was a kid,
just because after school
programs and then what's fun?
It's such a good one for kids,
man.
It was fun.
That's why I liked it.
I kinda set all that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
it was cool.
But um,
yeah.
And then,
uh,
I think I almost got my yellow belt.
Then my mom kind of pulled me out cause
I was just wrecking shop around the
house,
kicking everything.
I broke my arm doing backflips off
the couch and she was just like,
Nah,
no more.
And um,
yeah I found a young buck 20 job film.
I found that,
uh,
maybe in two,
2008 yeah,
2008 early 2008 I found
that and I was about 18.
He knows like,
Yo this is cool.
I didn't know what this is.
And then I found that was Moitai found
the Muy Moitai gym and then six weeks
later I had my first fight.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And I found a video of that first part,
actually I'll throw it up 18 I was 18.
Yeah.
But I'm glad people are like,
oh isn't that a little bit too late?
But I'm glad that happened because
I didn't feel like I was born out.
Cause I've seen some kids who proteges
fighting from like the age of 12 or 10
and then you like no smoking sheriffs
and then like they get to a certain point
and they just like,
I want to do something else.
Not all of them.
Some of them,
sometimes they come back as well but
sometimes they just find out that I'm sick
of this,
you know,
I want to do something else.
You find that a lot with
like sons of trainers.
It was actually the son of one of my,
my first trainer and he's
doing something else now.
But yeah,
for me I think 18 was a good year,
like good age to start
and I just felt fresh.
It was something I want to
do after my first fight.
I was just chasing that again,
that feeling because I've
always been a dancer as well,
so I liked that roar of the crowd.
So after my first fight getting
people like probably that was sick,
remember that.
And I'm like,
what the fuck did I do?
I don't remember it.
He just went into a zone.
Yeah Bro.
I was scared.
The guy looked like David Toy,
you know when David too had the aircraft,
he was no 80 kgs.
He was probably like maybe 92 Mike,
what is 92 and Katie's pounds.
Okay.
Maybe two or five.
So 80 Katie's would have been like
say when 85 one 75 or something.
So he was way over where yet,
but my train of kind of just,
he was a crazy dude.
So he just let it go and that when you
got to realize that at a certain point I
realized,
okay,
this is not the guy to get me
to that level I want to be.
So I left and I moved to Auckland,
New Zealand,
Auckland,
the main city.
What's your trainer encouraging
brawls too much or what was it?
He wanted me to fight his style.
Like what was that like?
You'd always telling me like you need
to have your hands up and you know,
he was a real purist of more time.
So he wanted me to have that,
you know,
like the right way and stuff like that.
And that's the difference between someone
that wants you to fight like them.
And someone like Eugene and
my coach when he first saw me,
he just like,
cool,
we can work with that.
Like he will let,
he never tried to make
me fight any and like,
like him,
he never tried to make me
do anything like this guy.
He just said,
okay,
I want you to jab like this.
And he would almost be like trying to
get someone to write songs like the songs
they,
right,
exactly.
It's like this is expressions is art.
Let me do me.
And it really is.
Yeah.
And he could never understand that.
He was like put your hands up.
And I,
I like my people said Y'all
and people would still say,
get your hands up.
I'm like,
that's textbook.
I don't read the textbook.
I had to look at it.
It was all right.
I like the balance.
I feel when I'm over here,
like my takedowns,
I was able to stop them because my hands
are already low and I can still show up
when I need to.
I can still find hands up when I need to,
but I like my hands down
aeration when you have to stop.
Take downs.
Yeah.
Even the kickbox and my hands were
always down a lot of the times.
Having the ability to get an under hook
or double under hooks quickly putting
kickboxing.
I like my job from there.
From the lowest,
from the lungs because gone,
there's definitely pros
and cons to everything,
but a guy who's got the kind of speed
that you have can take advantage many
times more of having hands low.
It really depends.
I mean look at Roy Jones,
how the fuck you say,
how can you fucking you
say hands down is no good.
Ryan Jones junior kept his hands down.
All that ties as well.
You have to,
I think you can train the
eyes because my eyes weren't,
I was always like had really
quick reflexes but I think
you can train the eyes
in certain ways.
The Roy could just land
that lead level like a jab,
like his,
his shoulder,
I think snap.
Yeah.
Crazy.
I remember that one with the fall,
right hooks.
He hit that guy with,
remember he had giant biceps
but he didn't have big triceps.
Like everything was hooks.
It was all like from throwing punches.
That's the thing that most people
were always leading with jobs as well.
So that would never
help him lead left hook.
That was something different at the
time that no one could figure out.
They couldn't crack the code.
Roy Jones Jr in his
prime and people people,
it's like a song,
it's like a song be tough.
Forgot or they forgot.
Y'All must've forgot that was his song.
His people did forget.
But the first box I ever
saw when I was a kid,
cause I never really watched fights.
I was playing with
sticks towards whatever,
making my own ship.
I saw Prince Naseem I met and I
remember this when I was about four,
but he will,
cause I always seen boxing on TV,
but he was the first box I saw that just
made me pause and watch and just smile
and laugh.
Like what is this?
Oh he was doing crazy shit.
Just cause the way he moved.
And guys,
I've always,
I've always been drawn and guys like that.
Like Ali,
even Rashad when he was in
his prime doing this thing,
um,
uh,
Roy Jones,
you know like porno,
woulda,
coulda,
sweet pea.
Like just people forgot about Whitaker.
Exactly.
It slept on them.
That shoulder roll.
I mean he was a master at that before
we really saw it from Mayweather.
Mayweather obviously has math.
He gets hit less than
anybody that's ever lived.
Yeah.
Do you think about the fact that guy
is 50 and [inaudible] and really,
I mean you think about
talks while it doesn't,
there's no slurring can count.
Yeah.
I mean clipped him with one left hand,
like real clean and that was it.
Uppercut.
Yeah.
I mean with a couple other punches
but none of them were like dangerous.
He rolled with them.
Yeah.
I rolled with everything
in my fight cause I,
I won't point after I felt his jab,
I was like,
you know what,
I can just close the
distance a little bit more.
And then that's how I got
the shiner right here.
But the right hands,
this right side's fine cause I was
just rolling with a lot of them.
I was rolling with a lot of them.
So you just underestimated his jab.
I underestimated his
head movement at first.
So the beginning he was moving away
from my jab and then you just said,
or I drop it down,
drop it down to the Chin a little bit.
And I did.
Um,
but eventually I could adjust.
I think from round two
I figured out the range,
but his jab,
it wasn't as powerful
as I want to as I ask.
I assumed it would be.
So I thought,
oh I can just take and give.
And that's how I got the shine.
I ran into one of them.
But yeah,
it was a big mistake.
Silly mistake.
So,
uh,
on the same card,
Uriah hall fought Polo Kosta,
a lot of people are thinking that might
be the next fight for you told Dana
funny stories.
So went to him after my fight,
I told him I would tell her I'm
just hanging out with my boys.
But then after dance,
if I went out and,
um,
someone told me,
Oh,
Dan is in this club,
he's the same.
I was all cool.
That's whatever.
And when I got some money and I was
talking to the guy to lead me and then
because he found out I'm a UFC fighter,
he just led me to the private
room and I see Mcmahon,
I'm like,
what the hell?
And they were just thought yarning.
I talking to people and he's an should
Dana and I finally meet Dana properly and
we start talking and I
dropped his name in there.
I said,
yeah,
I want to fight Paula next.
And he's like,
they have other ideas,
you know,
fair enough.
But I can,
they've done this a long time.
They're promoters,
you know,
so I think what they want is me,
being a bigger name,
Paul being a bigger name and we
fight like in some super fight.
I can see what that,
you know why that boy for me,
I want to,
I want to take him out now.
He just knocked out,
reorder hall was talking Mad Shit as well,
you know.
But yeah,
I want to take him out now before cause
he's going to eat before we fight again.
We'll probably fight more
than once cause he's,
he's the one of those guys.
Well we'll see what happens.
How long has the UFC career last?
But I think we'll probably fight with me.
And you appropriate five more than once.
Yeah,
I would imagine that as well.
I was very impressed with
him versus Uriah Hall.
It was interesting because the contrast
between your fight on Friday night in
his fight on Saturday night,
that was just a bra.
Like a technical bro.
He got hit with a lot of jabs,
but he is a relentless
marauding y'all the fucker.
That guy is.
He's very,
yeah.
And this thing's free footwork.
Uriah Hall.
I was watching my why you right there.
It's easy to look good at getting
someone who just sits right there like a
punching bag.
You know,
you Riaa had tremendous potential and
when we saw him in the ultimate fighter,
we all saw it.
But it also might be similar to what you
were talking about with sage Northcutt
where who are also thinking as Trump
still has tremendous potential and still
very young.
I think there's an approach to take
that you took that I
think is really smart.
You know,
I got it from one of the talk shows you
if she talk shows Katie floor and just
said it.
He said,
um,
get your experience outside of
the UFC before you go in the UFC.
Wise words,
10 fights,
nine fights and just like
fight a lot of good guys.
Not just like,
you know,
listen to me man.
You don't want to fight
you on your second fight,
right?
Imagine you're a guy,
you could throw a couple of good punches,
you think you're a bad ass and
then your stupid coach says,
okay,
you're going to fight this guy.
They call him the style bender like,
okay,
I'll fuck up.
I'll fight anybody.
You all fight for the title.
Yeah.
Those guys,
they get lit up and they don't understand.
They really don't understand.
Jumping in the pool too.
Quick conversation with a friend
of mine who was a Jujitsu,
he was bad ass did you do too?
And he said,
um,
he was going to uh,
go into MMA and I'm like,
okay,
how long have you been training striking?
And he's like,
well you know he goes for the last four
months pretty regularly or are you out
of your fucking mind?
I go,
listen to me man.
He was a black belt in Jujitsu,
nasty on the ground.
I go,
think about what you could do if I was
a white belt and I came in here and I
didn't know shit and I was
like a strong guy or maybe uh,
you know,
played basketball or something like
that was just an athletic and I tried to
fight you.
How bad would you fuck me
up on the ground right now?
Think of someone doing the exact same
thing like that to you with stand up cause
you don't understand that
there are guys who can do that.
Tyrone Spong there's you,
there's these high level kickboxers it,
you don't have a chance.
You think you have a chance because
you're fast and you don't have a chance,
you're going to get hit,
you're going to get fucked up and you
got to get hit multiple times and they're
going to chip away at you until they
decided to move in for the kill.
And then they're gonna fuck you up.
It's not a damn thing
you could do about it.
And it's almost the same as
him grabbing a white belt,
let them flail around and
then eventually choking them.
It's an inevitable thing.
But the weird thing is
some people don't see that.
They don't see that someone could
do to them in a certain art.
They don't study activity.
Yeah.
That's the thing for me.
I'm always thinking like in anything,
why am I doing this?
Why am I feeling this way?
Right.
A right or wrong.
And that's why I said I
moved to him and made,
cause I just know I want to be the best.
You know,
I couldn't be in the best kickboxer ever.
I can live with that best boxer as well.
But I just thought in my,
Milan is a guy who
could fuck you up fight.
It's not just on the ground.
I've seen so many street fights,
so many streetlights.
I'm like,
dude,
just put your knee down.
It was like just holding
each other and just hitting,
hitting.
I'm like,
you can easily just check the guy.
Right.
And if you knew what you were doing,
so that's a [inaudible].
He's a champion.
80% of street fights end up on the
ground and people don't know what they're
doing.
So I just felt like I never want to be
in a situation where a guy like gets me
in an alleyway and tries to like fuck me
up and just snap my uncle or some shit.
But I just feel like I want
to be able to be well versed,
take care of all areas and I'll probably
never get there or I'll die trying.
Well how old are you now?
28 I'll be 29 to in a few years on.
Still literally,
you're still at least a year or two
years away from your suppose at physical
plant,
right?
An athlete.
They,
they say that for a professional athlete,
obviously they say,
what does that everybody's variables.
There's something around age 30 to 32
will your mind and body catch up and you
have a window.
They're like Anderson Silva when
he was like 30 to 32 woo going,
I remember that.
You would watch him.
You just like put your
hands to your head and go,
Gee,
the first one I saw live was UFC.
He fought Patrick Otay.
Oh yeah.
But like for me that feels very smart.
But that first round he uses like probably
seven different styles to just hit
him.
And then I keep saying he
uses telekinesis on his knee.
He just it out.
But like Patrick had a fucked up need
going into that fight I think already it's
hard.
Hard to tell,
but it seemed like it gave Alpha flight.
It was a good fight.
He just stood on end.
It's like Ah,
like went to like throw a front
kick and it just buckled on.
It popped out.
Yeah,
not but like that fight that first round,
the way he just handled him.
I was like that.
Yeah.
That's the guy.
You know what,
it really did open up the recipe to
giving Anderson trouble though because the
recipe to giving Anderson Start Talis
latest opened it up and so they might
know.
But the real key was don't engage
because if you chase after him,
he's gonna fuck you up.
Like Stryker,
Forrest Griffin,
all these different people
that came at him up for sure.
Chris Leben.
That was how the first one,
92nd recipe for disaster.
I mean I knew when I saw that
fight on paper I was like,
oh,
this is crazy.
Oh you got a guy who's like the most
reckless iron chinned marauder in the UFC
and you're putting up against a guy who's
like a Ninja and this is going to be
crazy and this is a perfect fight.
It was a perfect fight in terms
of like what you want to see,
like the effectiveness of
like high level timing,
speed and perfect technique.
Like whoa.
The way he did it as well as clean.
I think he only got hit once that fight.
He let it like 100% of the shots.
Yeah.
And that fight.
Yeah,
it was beautiful.
Crazy,
and that's how I started.
I was a counter strike at first.
That's when I started.
I was always like,
I'll wait for guys to come in here.
Here it is right here.
Call and tell people because I was afraid.
I was a fan of Anderson's
from watching him fight.
Look at that Jab.
I was a fan of watching him fight in
England and cage rage and watch him fight
and pride and I remember saying this,
ladies and gentlemen,
this is a different kind of Stryker.
This is,
this is one of the first times you
got a high level look at the looks.
He's given them as well to show the
faints and the various of his feet.
Man Bounce.
He's on.
People forget man.
Look how good he paying.
He's already,
he's over.
Yeah.
Pain,
pain.
Pawlik at that come on site for him
to get up again and then me pain,
pain,
just as hurt.
Let me come on man.
Almost every shot lands.
He's not getting home.
It's incredible.
It's over insane.
Chris was a beast man.
He could take a shot.
He could take it all the time.
There was one with them was not my Easton.
It was a guy,
a rock them and he has,
he's moving back as
he's hurt and he drops.
The guy knocks him out to hold.
Yeah,
no,
Chris could take a tremendous shot.
He was had unbelievable heart.
But Anderson,
I feel like in that,
that's my argument for
Anderson being the goat.
There's more,
it's him and feed or,
right.
Yeah.
I saw as kid though,
the day after my fight,
I didn't record it.
I was like,
in the elevator,
you're Anderson's son.
He's like,
yeah,
baby goat.
But the only other person is the
current guys is mighty mouse.
The argument against mighty
mouse is he's cleaned out,
division out.
He doesn't have a Chris Weidman and you
know a guy who's trying to fuck him up.
He doesn't have like someone who you
really give a chance to the level.
Right.
I mean there's never been a
situation where like mighty mouse,
mighty mouse had a chill son and who had
him down on points in the fourth round
fucking him up and then he
catches them in a triangle.
No,
that flyaway definitely
wait and he dominates man.
He just runs through people.
Is he going gonna fight him?
What's his name on next mighty mouse
is fighting to Hutto in a rematch,
which he stopped better.
Who to go better and um,
since the first fight.
Yeah.
So who does a Olympic
gold medals and wrestling.
That's all you need to know and
to stand up as well as clean.
He's Kinda improved.
I'll give them Qualicum credit.
Yeah.
Wilson Hayes fine.
He looked like he was crazy.
Almost like McGregor out.
Yeah.
It was weird.
So he can learn fast.
It's another guy.
Great at wrestling.
Transfer that greatness into learning.
Stand up at night.
It just mixing them together.
That's the thing.
If you have to look at GSP that just
learning how to like Mesh them together
without like getting stuck on
thinking too much is flowing with it.
Yeah.
That's the key.
I think particularly the Wilson hates
fight because it showed that he can adjust
his style like pretty radically
when he walked out like this.
I remember going,
Whoa,
karate man,
this is crazy.
Give him credit where credit's due.
Well again,
when you're a gold medalist
in the Olympics in wrestling,
that's a special kind of human being.
That's the next level.
It's just a special kind of human being
and the wrestling training I do now,
I'm like fuck.
Sometimes we have on Wednesdays on
Wednesdays it's a vo two max color rate
wrestle Wednesday just cause it's
like air dyne and then wrestling.
It's two minutes on the airdyne
going hard with a heart rate monitor,
trying to get to the red zone and then
wrestling for two minutes trying to get
to the red zone and shot to Kevin,
Kevin Bentley.
He's the guy that showed me the most,
this camp.
So you know that my hips were on point
because every time I'd like stuff or take
down and get back up,
right.
Boom.
Another one that I have to like Jesus
Christ is leave me alone cause he's just
on you like a blanket like yeah.
So that kind of work as hard.
So imagine being a gold medalist.
What kind of wrestling training
it takes to get to that level.
Well that's why when you see a real high
level wrestler against almost everybody
else,
they have such a no dige
advantage in the clinch.
Like Daniel Cormier,
tp meal church this weekend.
I mean Dominick Cruz,
it was such a,
we're very fortunate to have a
guide that knowledgeable in cause.
Dominic's knowledgeable about basically
everything he started out as a wrestler
but he understands MMA as good as anybody
that's ever talked on the mic about
MMA.
He's very clued up.
So when he talked about like he showed
me some stuff that I hadn't caught about
Daniel's giving up the underhook so that
he could limp arm and then Steve Bay
would run right into the right hand and
they had it all timed out.
I've really broken down the file.
It's just I was already looking
at a time and I was lazy.
I was yelling off my
face just like wow dude,
when he connected and then he hit him.
I don't even know if I said anything cause
I remember I was going like I thought
was be five rounds,
five rounds.
There was a Deja Vu moment
like the world just changed.
He just knock them out of nowhere and
it was so close on the ground and it
stands up to the picture
I put on Instagram.
That is a beautiful picture of it cause
they've been working together for so
long.
When Jon Anik stands up and he DC looks
in here when they looked at each other,
look at that picture.
Come on man.
Who the fuck else is a two time world
champion in two divisions and also a
commentator currently and
a great working two jobs.
God I love that guy man.
I got these chunky as well
cause he just like chuck.
He's a nice way of putting it.
No honestly these Chunky,
maybe there was a girl,
what would you call her?
Thick,
thick boy.
Like he doesn't give a fuck.
This ain't even fat shaming.
That's the God damn two division champion.
I was talking to he and his nutrition
and he says like two 46 boy,
it doesn't move like two 46 I was like,
yeah,
100% so it's deceptive.
You look at him like even my hunt,
he's another guy like that.
But last Saturday,
the way he was moving,
well Javier Mendez was talking
about it and then camping.
So was Bob Cook.
They were telling me after the
fight they go dude and heavyweight,
he's knocking everybody
out and training part.
It's about strike for us.
How about that?
They heard that a lot of strife,
undefeated Strikeforce,
fucking Grand Prix,
heavyweight champion
tossing the upper neck,
big flood,
dropping them,
all that kind of shit.
I was like,
and that was brought up with five
rounds and he wasn't even like,
he was early.
That was early in his career.
So I was like,
you guys all understand.
So I thought was going to be DC,
putting them against the fence,
grinding them out for five rounds and
still beating them up for like fucking
them up and back and forth.
But knock in the first round.
That was just
crazy.
I thought DC was going to win it.
What was gonna happen was they were going
to get into the second and third and
they were going to start getting tired.
DC's restaurant was going to take over.
Those are the five rounds,
unanimous to DC,
but I felt like he had to somehow or
another where Steve pay out a little bit
before he gets takedowns and
get him back against the fence.
I thought that would be
the smart thing to do,
but I thought it was real dangerous
standing up because Steve pays,
knocked out junior dos Santos.
Alistair Overeem knocked out for
preschool for doing with one punch.
I mean,
you think all the people,
Steve Bay's knocked out and you go,
damn.
And dcs coming up as a light heavyweight.
DC CDC hurt was a rumble.
Right?
Well,
Jon Jones,
obviously John Jones Jones knock them out.
Yeah,
forget that.
John capitalized
brilliantly on a tendency.
You know,
he knew that DC,
he talks about leading.
What's interesting is that Dominick
Cruz explained this to me as well,
is that this is how DC prefers to set up
the single and that he prefers to lean
it on that side,
leaning towards his right side
and then dive in on the single,
that's his,
his preferred technique is very strong
and dragging you to the ground from that
position.
So you have the tendency,
every level.
John Jones,
myself,
when I was watching my fight,
I've only seen it once.
I was after the fight rewinding,
I took about an hour and a
half to finish watching it.
Just rewinding,
playing,
drinking with my friends,
whatnot,
because they understand that I just
like to be with myself and just chill.
So they just doing their own thing
and then we'll just playing games,
but I watch it to see what I did
right and I enjoy it was okay,
this is what I did,
good,
blah,
blah.
But then I see if I
was fighting me harder,
fuck me up now.
Ooh,
yeah,
I can see certain things.
Okay,
this is,
I need to work on tendencies,
certain tenants and change it up.
Confused people,
scramble them.
Some of the things I
was doing in that fight,
I've never done it in training.
Cause example,
elbow pads we don't,
I haven't really worn that will
pass and training just knee pads.
I was using that ung back elbow to set
up how to close the distance and I was
watching it.
I was like,
what did I learn that from?
I don't know,
like watch.
I did it probably three times.
I'd use the fake young buck elbow to
close the gap and I'd Gallop in and catch
him with a right hand or something.
But I never like certain certain things
like that were were things like they're
good but then I can't really say
the kind of thing you did that.
Yeah,
don't.
Yeah.
Do you think that maybe
that when you learn,
it's almost like you're learning words,
like in these words are techniques
and then combinations or sentences.
And then in like the having
the mastery of all these words,
you just see a new sentence
that you could say,
yeah,
I was like already know how I throw those.
Obviously even though you
don't do it a lot in sparring,
he just sees something he's doing like,
you know what,
this is what I'm going to
this and then come in here and
yeah,
like that one was nice,
but there was one of my last
fight before that and Arizona,
um,
Sean O'Malley throws dislike spin
and then the head kick in the fight.
I was like,
it feels right.
Boom.
First time I ever landed it.
And it caught him on the back
of the head and I was like,
oh good.
And I just kept them moving with it.
Jack Rule,
when Yahya Rodriguez ThreeSixty
roundhouse kicked Bj Penn in the face.
I was like,
yeah,
you gotta be fucking kidding.
Cause I was always wondering
when are we going to see this?
I've done the one I knocked out,
knocked down a heavy weight with it,
like a tornado kickoff.
And I learnt that about a
month and a half before.
Shout out to David.
He's the guy,
he's a taekwondo champion
from New Zealand.
And he told me,
cause I should throw it with the right
roundhouse and then spin with it and he
said that's too much telegraphing you're
showing the guy I'm going to kick it
cause he'll lean back and he'd come back.
So he said go south
port and use your torso.
So I'll give it away.
You throw your shoulder,
your left shoulder from south port
to call her after a few right hand.
So he kind of hammer throw a right hand
and then spin that spin right there
cause y'all ain't taekwondo
national champion.
So you know,
so that spin right there generates the
force and I was able to knock down,
knock down the guy with it.
I never had anybody with that
heavy bag with that a lot.
Exactly.
Make sure they can't move.
So I'd like to do it when they're
against the fence or they're against the
ropes.
So that way they have
nowhere to go or not.
Not as much space to,
to move around.
But if you're in the open
and talk to land land that,
you know,
what's really a remarkably effective is
that Raymond Daniels sidekick to jump
spinning back kick.
I can do it on the bag.
Yeah,
I definitely have did
it in sparring before,
but when I saw Rick,
Rufus w the one of his first fights,
it's really important
fight with a Thai champion.
Well,
he was fucking him up in the first round.
We played it back because it
was a really interesting moment.
I think on Youtube it's labeled as the
most important fight and kickboxing.
And what it was was the first fight where
we got to see Rick Rufus in his prime
face,
a Thai champion,
and this dude and Rick was
winning in the beginning.
And one of the things
that he hit him with,
he did,
he did that touch side kick,
spinning back,
kick in the air.
This is the fight that change history.
Is this a Lawrence can chain as well?
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh,
that guy's a treasure.
Love his work.
Yeah.
Go Google him,
uh,
or check out his videos on youtube.
He's got so many,
he had just had a breakdown.
I like the way they kind of
work off each other as well.
Like a lot of these guys,
they don't really,
um,
there's no competition.
They all working through to get a
full report and Robin black as well.
All these guys,
he's crazy.
But I really love about Lawrence though,
is that,
you know,
he breaks down things and shows him in
slow motion as is Brenda Dorman and Jack
Slack.
There's a lot of these guys that do this.
Was that,
I don't remember.
I don't remember how much Rick Wade,
I know he went up to like 200 pounds,
but I think he started out in the sixties
or seventies at the most because this
Thai guys pretty thick
and I got the pants.
Yeah.
Well he didn't understand how
to deal with the leg kicks.
This was,
this was a chewed him up,
but early in the fight,
I think in the first round,
see what this is showing is how the tie
starts taking over with the leg kicks.
But I think in the first round
he hit him with that sidekick,
uh,
jumps,
spinning back,
kick to the face and really hurt him.
Yeah.
This is a Lawrence is breakdown instead.
This is,
this is just going to show how he lost,
see how he tried to throw that
body kick and the Chi checked.
Yeah.
Let's fall by two.
The hit him with,
oh,
he heard him with that left hand.
He dropped it.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
No,
Rick had his moments in
this fight and for sure.
And um,
it showed just what a
dangerous striker he was,
but we didn't,
we just really didn't know
back then about the leg kicks.
Yeah.
I felt some Thai guys,
the legs,
the legs literally feel
like just concrete.
Yeah.
They're broken down from years.
Mine.
All right.
Like I,
it feels like a stegosaurus.
Stegosauruses back with
some times when you feel it.
It's like steel too.
I felt so the first time
somebody kicked me in my leg,
I felt so vulnerable because I
couldn't believe how easy it was.
Hundred percent.
I was the first,
my first thought was,
God damn.
And I have to recalibrate
everything I thought about fighting.
I fought at Karate Guy a cure cause she
can guy a and maybe two hours notice
cause my appointed decided at the winds.
He's like,
I'm not fighting him,
but what you do that made
him say that a black.
And then this Guy Jamie [inaudible]
who I fought I think four times now.
So he came over to corner one of his
teammates and he was a national QCC Shin
champion cause I'll fight him.
Cool.
Jump in the ring and it's padded.
Fight everything.
Uh Yep.
Two leg kicks in.
I was like,
whatever I can keep going.
And then by the fourth
one I remember like,
Ooh,
okay,
don't do that again.
And then from there it was too late.
That was only in the
first round eight my legs,
he ate my legs.
And I remember for about
three weeks after that fight,
walking was just,
I didn't want to walk.
Every time I'd be like,
can you pass me this all just like
crawling places and the hate walking.
But Fun family.
How long?
About three weeks,
maybe two,
two and a half,
three weeks after that fight.
And it's just,
you know,
your legs are dead heavy,
filled with blood and bruises and it's
just any little movement because your
knees are swollen as well.
Sharp pain.
A hated it.
Fucking hate take before you recovered.
Probably.
Yeah,
about three weeks.
Four weeks I heel Quik like honestly,
it's weird.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I Dunno why he called to
her when he fought Pedro.
His owed needed six months of Rehab,
six months to six man,
it still has a dent in his leg
apparently from that fire shit,
Pedro gave a Denta
Kevin random until shit,
I never saw anybody kicked it
back like Pedro or kick a people
[inaudible] hills Jujitsu and like the,
the mid nineties and Bas
Rutten was running it back
at the time and Pedro Huizar
was over there.
That blue box dude he had,
they had this big ass 200 pound fucking
heavyweight and Pedro his are folded.
That thing should,
it made me so nervous.
Was it hanging off the ground or was it
sound?
I don't think maybe is the bones.
I think it's just heavy bones as well.
Dance Motherfucker,
Dick Dude,
pick boys.
Legs were giant,
but it was,
there was a feeling of this very,
you know,
sometimes you hear someone or you see
someone kicked something or something and
you go,
oh,
I could never that no one gave that.
You can't take that.
Pedro had that you had that,
you can't take that.
He hit Rico Rodriguez
once and Rico was like,
fuck this.
I'm going down to check it out.
He's like,
I just tried to bring this guy in my Gar.
You Man,
I'm,
I stand up with you.
He hit him so hard that
Ricoh stayed on the outside,
the whole fight.
He never really,
he never really completely committed
to trying to win the fight heavyweight.
Right.
That's the guy with the,
um,
the problem PD problem.
The wrong guy.
Rico,
did people get popped for PE news?
Maybe.
I don't,
there's a documentary on them.
No,
no,
no.
You're thinking of Mark Carr.
Uh,
Rico.
I don't think Rico got popped ever.
But Rico was a Machado.
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
Now heavyweight champion.
I don't think I have an American wrestler.
I think Tim Silvia beat him for the title.
Tim Sylvia,
when he was at the top of his game,
he's a big giant,
motherfuckers still fighting retired now.
He bow hunts in Iowa.
All giant now.
Shit,
he's 300 plus and he's
like six six foot nine.
A huge,
huge,
huge person.
Boy.
I always looked at him.
One thing I was just gumby,
like a big guy,
but he could fuck people up.
Hey.
Yeah,
and he was like,
you know,
like,
like we,
we didn't get a baby giraffe
trying to figure out its steps,
but he just knew how to move and
how to use it to his advantage.
Well,
if you go to the golden age of Tim Silvia,
pull up Tim Silvia Kaos Rico Rodriguez.
This is the golden of Tim Silvia.
Back when Mexican supplements are easy
to come by and find out that the drug
tests back then was like,
they would like to make up,
fill out a piece of paper.
Tell me what drugs you
passed the test.
I wrote zero.
It was fucking,
everybody was on the,
I want to see men with
all this stuff on PD,
kind of talk for me.
I kind of thought yeah some people pause,
take steroids,
whatever.
But after I seen ICARUS,
everyone's on steroids.
Everyone in a lot of
broad holy shit the fuck.
I was just like everyone not,
but like there's the cheater are
always going to be a head of the,
the solution.
The guys were catching them
so whoever's on the new shit,
they can't get caught just yet.
Or they update their testings.
You know what I mean?
So it's like I watched that and I realized
if you have the team behind you and
you have people can fund it.
Everyone's on steroids up.
They hold their pis for a long time.
Right.
Don't they hold your pissed
for like eight years.
I told him just yeah,
use it for research or whatever.
Yeah.
But I think they hold onto it just in
case new testing comes out so they can
test it again.
They took gold medals away
from two Russian cats.
Oh yeah.
Cause they went back and
with new testing found,
I think they found EPO and their sisters.
Shit.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
That documentary was amazed.
Change my open my eyes and I had
a piss test the next day as well.
I was like,
yeah,
I told the guy,
oh,
I've seen this.
I saw this on,
on the documentary last night.
Like the Little Cup they were using.
So yeah,
I was like,
who knows who on steroids when
you saw that came through,
you know the guys that kind
of like their body's changed.
Some of the people dropped off radically.
Yeah,
Greg,
so quick,
really quick.
It's like,
whoo.
I never thought,
not just changed,
but changed to the point where like
you're not even the same person.
Yeah.
And the guys in their 20s
doing an impression of who
they were just a couple of
years ago in the sauce.
Yeah.
Shit's happening,
man.
Everyone,
I'm snitching.
That's the golden snitch.
He's a man.
He sent it to me.
He was texting me as well.
Novitsky he's a good guy,
man.
He's just like,
he's got a bad reputation
from a lot of people.
Like,
it'd be cool with them cause I
know me and I'm not cheating.
I'm not a guy that never interested me.
What is his official title?
It's like athletes.
Those cheat on wouldn't be hanging around
him like the why I would or wouldn't
be as friendly with them because
they didn't want him sniffing around.
You know what I'm saying?
He's there to make sure that someone
doesn't cheat on youtube though.
100% I'm like please,
I'm not mad at it.
What's that?
What does it say?
The golden snitch.
The golden snitch is the vice president
of athlete health and performance with
the UFC
made it
golden.
God Damn,
that's funny.
Yeah.
Oh Shit,
I'm glad he's around man.
Honestly,
cause you know you want out of mind
being an ambassador for the sport if it's
not like a clean sport.
Cause yeah,
back in the day,
even as early as 2010 hey
finding 12 Tim Silvia,
Silvia Rica,
Roger,
but it's only on fight pass and I don't,
that's it.
I can't find it anywhere.
Damn.
He sounds just like the voice of
my own for a lot of different ways.
It's weird like when you look
at him talking to us like,
oh right,
cause you heard about 20 times.
Yeah,
I know.
It's weird being here.
It's weird for me too man.
Believe.
Yeah,
bro Freaks me out.
I quit my job September 4th,
2013 before I,
before I quit that job.
I think you are the first pause podcasts.
I started listening to you
and I've got a few others,
like a uh,
like a whole list.
But I remember having those
my headphones in my ear,
just one,
so I could focus on the other things
that my boss would just ride me for so
long.
Like just take that shit out.
Your heirs [inaudible] music.
I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm just trying to be entertained
so I didn't go postal and you niggas
that it was just,
you can enjoy what you do.
Some people fly.
When I was living in China,
I knew a lot of guys that fought,
but they didn't enjoy it.
They just did it because it makes good
money and they get paid and I'm like,
do something else.
But for me doing that job only
shit soul sucking every single day,
you know,
you wake up train and then it was just
a block away and not walk to work.
And I just knew I wasn't going to
get just written that day in men.
But it's kind of crazy now I'm checking
in like I'm actually out here like I've
listened to this for
so long and it's like,
yeah I belong here now.
Like it's weird.
Everything just seems normal.
Good,
good.
That's perfect.
That means you hit the right time.
Yeah,
it means you got a good sense of timing.
It's like,
cause sometimes like
everything in my room,
I had a nice suite for this
one shot to the UFC is that,
that that made events that as,
so I had like a nice little spot can
join the rooms with my teammates and
sometimes I'll just overlook the
t-mobile arena and just be like,
okay,
like we were like,
we've made it,
we're out here.
No we're not done yet.
But like,
yeah,
shit,
okay,
let's go.
And they just kinda checked back in.
You're in the UFC.
I mean you had to break into
the top 10 but that's fine.
I don't think the rankings have come out.
Fuck rankings man.
Honestly,
like so stupid.
They fucked up Paul Felder.
Paul Felder would've got
that shot against Khabib.
What does a welterweight,
so it shouldn't even affect,
it shouldn't even affect
the lightweight ranking.
No,
that I'm not talking about that fight.
I mean the reason why Paul Felder do,
you didn't get that fight with Khabib
and Tony Ferguson hurt his knee,
wouldn't recognize him.
He's wasn't ranked in the top 10 they
wouldn't recognize him to be thought of in
a great fight.
Great fight.
But I Quintell was a fucking
flight and handle that well.
But Paul Felder is a
big fucking lightweight.
Yeah.
And Paul Felder has outstanding striking
that there would be a real interesting
fight percent so just cause the rankings.
They didn't let that go
because the rankings,
the rankings.
That's one thing I want to know.
Who decides what the like is it like,
uh,
I,
she called me for that.
No,
but like what have they done?
What's their credentials?
Where are they trained?
Have they fought or they just like
analysts are they experts because it feels
like if you want to be,
instead of figuring out who did it,
let's think about what
you would do differently.
Like what,
who do you think should be,
who do you think should
be making the rankings?
The rankings?
Maybe x fighters,
x fighters or like,
um,
someone who's been in the sport,
someone who's trained.
He sent me,
like you said,
with judging someone who's actually like,
and the,
there's the shit out of me,
man.
After my,
my second fight in the UFC,
I fought in Glendale.
Right?
It was a split decision I got
in my head when they said,
you know,
Israel 50,
whatever,
oh,
sorry,
39,
38 is at a Sonia.
I was like,
Oh fuck God.
Just don't cause my wind bonus.
I don't give a fuck about my record.
I'm just like,
don't fuck me out of my money.
Don't fuck with my money.
Like one other incompetent
judge and that would be knit.
Yup.
Only half my money and
that would piss me off.
So crazy.
What have you done to like how
the fuck did I lose that fight?
In your eyes?
It is of the biggest problems that
I thought the commissions have.
Can't they just like,
it seems like it's too much work.
Like assuming that this should be
like a maybe a group chat like okay,
let's change the 12 to
six Albo who's agreed?
Yup.
Yup,
Cool.
That's a no brainer.
That one's the dumbest one of all time.
What is it,
why it takes so long to try and
make any change in the sport?
Well,
how about the way classes?
Jesus,
Kevin,
Kevin Lee tweeted the other day that
there's something like 150 different
fighters in between one 55 and one
70 or I think he said more than that.
I said,
what did he say about him almost dying?
He felt like he was going to
die when those came weight.
While definitely don't
[inaudible] 55 he that's scary.
It is scary and you should be probably
fighting at one seven one 65 class.
I read on that tweet.
Well,
it's a good class.
Yeah.
She'd be 55657580590 five to 25 I
can do one 81 95 if that was me.
I'll take that though.
I'd be jumping between those two.
Why not?
I mean that's doable.
I think the real problem is you give guys
like 85 two oh five that's 20 fucking
pounds,
man.
That's a lot of weight.
Yeah.
I walk around to a five if I'm healthy.
If from DC it out.
Well that's good.
That's a good amount of weight to cut.
Like I back.
When you get real lean,
you'll probably lose like six seven
and you're only losing really cutting.
Like what 10 this is camp.
I didn't use a song.
I didn't use a bath for this fight.
Nice.
Normally like the last two I did and I
was underweight just and I was only cut a
little bit as well,
but this one I woke up on.
Wait.
Do you use an expert to help you?
Like a Lockhart or something?
I'm gunna maybe for the fight week.
Use Lockhart next time maybe.
But like normally I just,
I,
I've done this for a long time,
so my,
I know my body and I'm
always accurate as well.
I can feel like,
man,
I'm about 98 kg or 93 kg.
Sit down.
I'm about 85.
Katie's right.
Rehydration Lockhart method,
the old one.
Um,
there's a whole system like with the
waxy maize amino acids eating pineapples
with crackers and honey and whatnot.
So I follow the list and my coach
pineapples with cracker and honey.
I don't know,
it's on the list.
It's a lock hard one.
That's a,
yeah,
it's like carbohydrates from the crackers
and the honey talking to the wrong
guy.
I would know what that kind of stuff.
Like for me,
I just,
that's the thing.
I have guys like Mike,
my coach or Eugene who knows why,
you know,
and he'll just tell me do this.
And I trust them.
Yeah,
I know it's a la carte method and they've
updated it because I talked to Ian and
he said that was the old one.
I sent it to him and he
said they've updated it.
So I said,
okay,
next time probably I'll use them to,
for the fight week,
wait,
cut.
And then the rehydration,
I'll try the toughest you've ever cut.
Like how have you ever gotten,
let me go back.
Go back.
Uh,
this is probably early on in my career.
No,
actually there was one in
China where I fucked up.
I was fucking around.
I'm at the buffet or something,
maybe like the fight week.
And then I think I cut
four cages in the sauna.
It was easy on the last one.
But before that I was just like
mentally sitting there like,
shit,
never again.
I'm never doing this again.
And I start to like
visualize the fight line.
I'm gonna make this guy pay and I
start to get delusional and delirious.
But yeah,
for Katie is not bad.
I've heard worse.
I've heard like six kgs in a,
in a sauna,
and that's a lot on like someone who's
not even that fat or that [inaudible]
1314 pounds.
How many of you in kgs?
Dammit,
I know.
Pounds.
How many pounds is that?
14 yeah.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
30 pounds.
2.2 so,
Oh God,
that's right.
I'm going the wrong way
and going the wrong way.
Oh,
here it is.
As you get closer to the
Wayne's,
we cut back on the fat and start
incorporating frozen fruits.
Interesting.
Something I use a lot is pineapple.
The reason is dietary
fiber will hold water.
If I put a bunch of water into a bowl
and let us let us Brown and wilted the
next day,
resorbed the water via a
small cyst would be good.
Lettuce again.
Well,
I didn't know that.
When you guys are near the
end of your weight class,
they are cutting back on how much water
they take in so they don't have to worry
about the body absorbing the water.
That means we can give them fruit,
the fruit,
which is going to help
them fuel the brain.
Interesting.
Hmm.
Yeah that interesting.
Huh?
Now what kind of shit do you eat?
Like are you on a very specific
diet or a sea food and I eat it.
I like food.
I'm hungry.
My bed,
the best thing is like for me,
it's weird when you're not allowed it.
You want it more?
Yeah.
Like fight week when I get here and I
started to like crave just the good stuff
and I go on these Instagram pages like
tasty and I used to wash and I save it
and I write down when I'm going to get,
when I get back home.
And then it's like food porn for real.
Yeah.
Just thinking about it.
Oh my God.
And then after the fight,
once it's time to weigh in,
I'm good and I'm just like all right,
eat healthy,
get it done.
I don't like pig out like even on the,
the one I get I'll go from Lockhart says
do not eat pasta until after the fight.
Cause apparently that
can still be no pasta.
Capital letters do not.
What about like maybe a keen
want pasta or lentil pasta?
That'd be better.
I think just like regular lanes.
Yeah.
I think just like maybe pastry pastor,
that kind of stuff.
[inaudible] Pasta,
not,
yeah,
I liked that one thing.
Do you have any elk?
Yes sir.
Yeah.
Come get here for a go to spot til
Thursday is can you have a place where you
can cook?
Oh Dude,
I got you.
Yeah.
The thing I'll give you is
I'll give you some elk sausage.
That's the easiest to cook and I'll give
you some directions and I'll give you
an elk stake direction.
Do you have access to like a a like
some sort of a a grill with a lid on it?
We can get a temperature control grill.
A barbecue grill.
Yeah.
We've got one.
As long as you get,
you just want to make sure and you've
got to get a digital thermometer.
You want to make sure the meat
stays somewhat temperature.
Yeah,
you don't want to keep it.
You definitely don't want
to Cook it past 120 degrees.
Easy to follow instructions.
Okay.
I'm coachable.
I know you are,
but you know you can't learn on your own.
I'm going to be so both.
The thing about a guy like you that's
interesting to me is like it's very
obvious that you have very good technical
training but then you deviated and you
figured out your own creative path
and something you said earlier,
which I think is really important and
it's a good thing to hear for people who
don't really understand martial arts
is what you do really is an art.
I mean you're expressing yourself,
you know there's something,
and for a person like me who's a fan of
that martial art and I understand what
you're doing,
I watch it and I'm appreciating it.
It's like I'm watching ballet or symphony,
I'm watching art.
I'm like,
oh look how he's set up.
There was one time when you trapped his
trapped his wrist and cracked him on the
elbow and I didn't know what that is is
that's like almost like NLP because some
people will use things coming
at them at a certain speed,
none that pop.
So what I did,
like he had his guard
up and I was just like,
just give me a hand and I
just hit him with a food.
So like he gave you watch it.
He kind of like just,
well he thought you were
going at a slow speed.
He sped up because I'm used to,
you know,
he's used to the fast they
can run them and I was like,
oh just give me your head.
Well that's the change up in baseball.
They throw a slow pitch and you're like,
what is this?
And you with it and you're like,
fuck,
how did I miss that?
Because you are expecting
a ball to be so fast.
I've heard the term before but I've never,
I don't know,
change up.
So if a guy throws like a
98 mile an hour fastball,
it all of a sudden he throws one
that's like a fraction of that.
I don't know what fraction baseball,
right.
Swing too quick or something.
Yeah,
they swing too quick.
Will it be a changeup pitch?
Like how much slower would it be?
20 or 30 miles an hour slower?
Yeah.
So if fucks your head up,
man,
you're expecting that
ball that comes through.
You see him throw it.
Yeah.
And then he fucking hasn't
even gotten there yet.
Deception.
That's what it is bro.
Like damages deception because
the ultimate deception,
I go a few more.
That's this the basic one I use,
but I got to,
I try one on him.
You might catch it.
It was a change up from a
left kick to a front teeth,
but it just went right.
It was right there.
We see the highlight.
Ooh,
that was pretty,
you know another one that
you see Wonderboy likes to
use is that front leg side
kick,
roundhouse kick combination.
He comes in and touches you with the
front leg side kick and then Saul swap.
Yeah.
Raymond Daniels though has the prettiest
version of that jumping sidekick
spinning back kick to the
face that he didn't glory,
that they'll sick.
I mean that guy did the splits.
Woo.
Damn.
That was a guy who can do that in a
kickboxing match and a very high level.
That's when you realize like,
Whoa,
this guy,
like you can't give him any road.
Yeah,
100% well that's why face
Joseph Valtellina and Nikki
halts can when they fought
him though.
It's sure.
Interesting.
Constant pressure in leg kicks,
chopping that leg,
chopping that leg.
You know what I like about your style is
you basically do both of those things.
You do the wild crazy shit but you also
do technical Moitai cause what I mean
about I kept on standing by
you or I'll be in a book,
but button basher like you know when you
play Tekken and you just kind of like
play into hope,
something cool happens.
That's what he does.
And I'm like established
your basics first.
Established Your Foundation,
Land Your Jab.
He did it in this last fight,
but like normally established something
first and then the f the cool shit comes
afterwards.
You can't just like,
and he's,
he's had success with knocked
out gay God with the spinning.
I'm jumping,
spinning back kick,
you know.
But like I think you'd have better
success at letting those things if you
establish your basics first land your jab,
set the pace.
He was landing a lot of jobs and that
fight in that last close to it was just
constant relentless with it's pressure.
I think I called it two
minutes before it happened.
I was like,
I told Ash,
um,
my,
a friend of mine was like,
he's phase phase and
he's going to go soon.
He's going soon.
You can just see it
when he starts to like,
and maybe cause I see it,
that's what I look for in a guy or
they tell me like I'm ready to go.
I'm like,
all right,
cool.
I hope you're out.
I was taking them out.
You can just find it like that.
You look in their eyes
when he killed them.
When you see guys starting to crack,
you feel them.
You feel them?
Well yeah.
You feel it's an energy.
It's the energy.
Like just see dressed.
Yeah.
And he's okay.
He's ready to go.
Like example,
my first flight shots or Rob Wilkinson,
I actually brought him
in just to help me out.
Not for this camp,
just before his wrestling pressure.
Rob Wilkinson,
he's a good guy.
He's my first UFC fight.
But when I was fighting him,
it was in the second round after his
last take down attempt and then I like
stuffed his head,
got my leg out and let's
get back to the middle.
And I saw him walk back like
circle and just the body language.
I was like,
oh,
you're ready.
Not Throw my hands up like what's up?
And then pop me a poem and I just
Kinda like just pick them apart slowly.
I didn't rush it.
Like I keep telling,
I don't rush these knockouts.
Like a lot of people were like,
oh,
he hurt Brad about three times,
but you know,
he didn't go for the finish.
I'm like,
I'm not trying to bum rush these days.
I just picked them apart.
They will fall eventually.
Well not only that,
but here's something to
consider for people that don't,
don't really totally
understand what you're doing.
You're doing everything correctly and
you're not really getting hit much.
No,
you,
you're doing everything correctly.
And by doing everything correctly,
you're kind of ensuring to continue your,
your domination in that fight
versus put yourself in danger.
Which some people like some people like
I like the fight down on her mouthpiece
and bang.
I love me adjusting,
gauging Michael Johnson,
but I'm not going to be that guy.
I'm not going to be that guy because
I'm not here for a long time.
I'm here for a good time.
I just want to keep my wits
about me like Mayweather,
get in,
get out,
making money and fuck off.
That's what I want to do.
You're finding correctly in terms of like
if you're trying to teach someone how
to hit and not get hit,
you're fighting correctly,
but in order to push further,
if you were trying to make it
more exciting and engage more,
you have to risk getting hit and
that's not a wise thing to do.
I take risks,
I like to take risks and
when I play with my distance,
okay,
am I too close my too far and I,
before I take those risks,
I calculate,
I know what he's going to do already.
I'm like,
I can bait them with something,
like if I want them to jab now,
get closer and when he
jabs I slipped and rip.
You know what I mean?
So you just,
I take a risk by calculating my risk and
sometimes I'm might do some wild shit
like that.
Have a narrow,
yeah,
I fucked up on that one cause
it was a little bit slippery.
And I uh,
I landed in training.
I've,
I catch it all the time,
but I didn't account for the sweat on
his legs and I got back up anyway and I
was like,
come on.
It was a good one,
you know,
but it's a crazy thing to do.
You're also very honest when
things don't go your way.
Yeah.
And then things go wrong.
You had a kickboxing fight.
Was it in glory?
Yeah,
no,
that was the one in Brazil.
What's,
uh,
what's his name?
Alex.
Yeah.
Per area where you lost and you were
talking about what it was like to get
knocked out.
Yeah.
For me that's everyone's worst fear.
So that for me was to
first for the first time,
my first back to back lost cause that
was just after the glorified and my first
knockout loss.
Although you lost a lot of people
thought you should won the decision.
I won the fight.
You know,
you look at it,
oh well I don't even base it on that.
But like we both knew like,
I hit you more than you hit me,
you know?
Yeah.
He was like,
well he had the pressure and he
walked you down in the commentary.
Being honest was bullshit because I mean
respect to a guy like val to leave me,
but he never,
he can't fight like me.
He can't understand my style,
his fight.
You look at his career,
he has to take time off because of,
you know,
trauma,
because that's how we fight.
So he appreciates that kind of style.
But what's his name?
Uh,
wellness.
Walk me down,
but he really couldn't do shit leg
kicks as opposed to slow you down.
I didn't slow down.
I was still dancing around
them in the fifth round.
I was slipping and stuff.
I was fresh.
You know,
but yeah,
that fight,
I felt like I won that fight,
but it's all right.
So,
you know,
it wasn't meant to be,
everything happens the way
it's supposed to happen.
I wasn't supposed to get that
belt and I'm okay with it.
Yeah.
Well the fight was the fight.
Exactly.
Really was just a,
the judges that people have a dispute
with the actual fight was a successful
fight for you and that you did
land more shots than he did,
but then losing the next fight by Kao and,
but you talked about it online,
like you were real open about it on
Instagram and because that's the fair,
like every fighter,
like if it was just me and
a guy fighting and I lost,
it's like,
oh,
whatever.
But when you put it in front of,
you know,
millions of people,
that's the fair.
It's like,
Oh shit,
I don't want to look like shit
in front of all these people.
What did you get hit with?
Um,
I was,
south port was a l a left hook from him
and before that first round I tee them
up second round.
I rocked him within from
that wellness fight.
I let some bull shit
get to me just online.
You know,
like people in your life is looking
different like people in your license.
Amen.
He should have won that fight,
blah blah blah blah.
Okay.
She shouldn't leave it
in the judge's hands,
you know,
they'll say some shit like that
and it just seeps into you.
So when I heard him in that second round,
I just went berserk what people expect
me to do and what people in the UFC do.
Just like Isiah throwing
bombs and just like I was,
no,
I was only throwing right hands.
I just thought only right hands at him.
And I watched that fight back.
I haven't watched it in a long time,
but when I watched it back I was like,
why are you doing this?
Because that's not me.
That's not me staying true to myself.
Well,
I would've done if I was,
you know,
being true to myself is just,
all right,
cool.
Where's the shot?
Bomb pop home.
Just pick him up.
He was hurt.
He was out on his feet already.
So it's a good story for him.
You know,
like he knocked me out at the third
round after he got in the second round.
But I mean,
yeah,
it was good for him.
But Hey,
if we fight again,
because even after my first my UFC debut,
he put like a contract up.
Like he's coming to the UFC as well.
I'm like,
all right,
make your way up.
I'll fuck him up 100%.
He's a very good kickboxer too.
I mean he
beat me twice and the first
time as well was another weird,
you know,
he's walking forward and you know,
not landing shorts,
but I'm moving back and hitting them
the whole time and the judges gave it to
him,
so I was like,
credit to you,
you got to fight.
I'll fight you again.
So if he makes his way to the UFC,
you can get it anytime.
Is he trying to fight MMA now or is he,
I think he hasn't.
He's had MMA fights he's had,
it may fights,
but a lot of kickbox is,
like I said,
my boy Brian,
even he realizes like
MMA is where it's at.
You know,
the UFC,
they see the way best run
company I've ever come across.
I fall around the world for,
for glory,
for in China.
No one runs the show like the UFC.
Like everything has a place in the time
and it's just so clean and you get your
money quick.
That's one thing.
I like it.
Fuck,
it's a well oiled machine.
Definitely mean they've,
they've been running it that way since
2002 and now the new organization is
basically like most of
the old organization.
Yeah.
It's nice to work for a man.
I still enjoy it after all these years.
Like the next one.
The next one's in La,
right?
Yup.
TJ versus Cody.
We magnify a fuck that first fight,
uh,
after the last Robert Whittaker,
Yo over Merrill fight that your weight
class is kind of in this weird state.
I mean,
um,
what do you mean?
Well,
it's,
Whitaker won the fight.
Um,
but a lot of people thought Ramiro might
have gotten the nod because he knocked
him down and hurt him and then he
heard him again and the next round.
A lot of people thought at the very least
it was a draw because if you look at
them on paper,
Whitaker never really hurt my Merrill,
but Romero did significantly hurt.
Hurt him.
Whitaker twice.
Yeah,
and you know he came off
of knocking out rock,
but then again he didn't miss wait,
so that kind of puts it out for me.
I really care.
As long as he's moving up,
I think,
I think he said he's going
to go to light heavyweight.
Yeah,
I think that's the most recent.
How tall is he?
Tall Dude.
That guy is built like a brick shit house.
Looks like an action figure.
When he came in here and do a
podcast while I was in camp,
you know him and Joey
Diaz translated and shit.
I was looking at my keys,
230 pounds.
He's fucking huge.
How's he going to make one 85 that's how
I felt when I first met Anthony Johnson
and I was like,
yeah,
why the fuck fuck.
I literally,
I saw him,
he's just like a thick burger,
like huge and he you didn't want,
he hit me once.
I think when it was only once,
like a clean one and I was like,
I'm not getting hit by that again.
Is it 100% it was good work.
I enjoyed the work.
We'd go out together,
but definitely you to get hit spar
or well he's called light with,
you know,
he
was the guy that brought
in front of mess up.
But yeah,
it wasn't,
I didn't let it happen.
Ooh,
how's making sure like
nuts stay away from that,
that there's one he teached me and I
went from one side of the case to the
other.
He hit me,
you know that tp does like a site tp
just pushing your luck in elliptical that
one yet I'm going to kick.
Yeah.
And he just did it and I went and hit
the fence on the other side and I was
like,
Yup,
he's a big boy.
And that was it.
I was probably maybe 90 cages at the time.
So that was about 200 pounds.
But yeah,
he's a,
he's a motherfucker.
You don't want to spar him.
You had to get down to a
five is a bit of a struggle,
which is just so crazy.
I gave him,
Hey,
you got this list as well?
It wasn't,
it was back from short.
Yeah,
100% but it was,
it was good work.
I have no idea.
I saw him in between fights at
one 70 and he was 230 pounds.
I was like,
what are you way you seen now?
He seen him on Instagram.
Yeah,
I saw him like couple of weeks ago.
It's just like
come back as a heavyweight.
Perfect dude.
He's and he already being a heavyweight.
He's me fucking do that heavyweight.
He just couldn't answer the the the puzzle
that was DC DC's the one that really
hadn't figured out.
Yeah,
DC just figured them out,
man.
He,
she just knew how to break them.
I think it's just the gas tank as well.
Sometimes like he puts his foot on the
gas too quick and also learning how to
not be conservative but
manage your gas tank.
Yeah.
He would just,
he would just swing for the fucking
bleachers as most of the time when he did
that,
he would just put guys in a coma,
you know,
and I just think at a
certain point in time,
you know,
he was on a tear.
He was at motherfucker,
he was at motherfucker for a long time.
Is that,
that one was the one he had with Glover.
Teixeira that didn't look like much,
not the uppercut.
It didn't look like much and it
was in the middle of a square,
like a scramble.
Like they were just working
in the dude's amazing.
It's turning them all with that.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he had ridiculous punching power,
like some of the most ridiculous
punchy power that Mark Hunt Him.
Uh,
it was another one.
Rampage had that as well.
Like I don't understand
[inaudible] and chuck,
what I liked that he had it was,
cause he was long as well.
He wasn't really a thick guy,
but I think it's as levers,
his arms,
he just knew how to whip that.
Uh,
if for,
what are they fighting?
He and though,
I don't know man,
but there's a video of chuck working out.
He's working out with Ray Sefo.
Shit.
Maybe I'll give them credit benefit
of the doubt because I'm lucky.
Maybe he hasn't hit pads in the wall.
Let's see.
Maybe three weeks from now.
Now I have no idea John.
Jay,
me pull that up.
I would think that
I felt good,
but uh,
uh,
yeah,
maybe four weeks.
Let's see if he,
if he keeps the training up,
he might,
it's like riding a black.
He didn't look like chuck of old,
obviously,
because we have something
to compare it to,
but he,
you know,
he just,
he's not going to be like that either way,
but let's see if it can be get better
from what that wasn't on Instagram.
He's a 49 year old guy and
he was probably warming up.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
He's
just him just throwing,
yelling out loose.
You still sparkling?
No Real,
no.
You roll.
I roll.
But I'm 50 years old.
I can't kill him for real.
I can't get hidden though.
Black don't crack.
Yeah,
I'm old enough to not be a willing
to get hit in the head anymore.
When I stopped,
when I was probably 28,
29 when I first moved to La,
I still did some kickboxing.
I went to Benny,
the jet center and a van eyes.
Remember Benny or Kitezh Benny,
the jet original Oji kickboxers
and him and blinky Rodriguez had a,
the jet center and Van Eyes.
And for me there was two things that I
wanted to do when I came to California.
One I wanted to go to hard times,
billiards cause hard times.
It Bellflower California pool.
Yeah.
It's one of the legendary
pool halls in the country.
And two,
I wanted to go the jet center and van
eyes and I went there do and it was all
like gang members and blinky Rodriguez
had like a program where he would uh,
let these gang members in and you know,
have them all take classes.
So you'd be sparring with like
hard to hardcore gang bangers.
They had like,
one dude had this like really shitty
tattoo on his back with his gang.
I forget the name.
And then it said,
fuck the rest on his back and we're
both putting in our mouth pieces.
I'm like,
Jesus,
what am I doing?
I grew up in the suburbs.
I kind of happened as like gang activity.
Kind of like just seeps
its way into a fight.
They fight.
They went to fight culture somehow.
Yeah.
It's also part of leaky,
I believe blinky Rodriguez
lost his son to gang violence.
All real.
Yeah,
so I did get an open up program,
but he was letting kids into the gym and
trying to help the community and help
these kids.
I'm,
I apologize if I got that wrong,
but I think I got that right.
Please look that up.
Blinky Rodriguez son
dies and gang violence.
I'm pretty sure that's true.
Blinky Rodriguez was a
famous kickboxer too.
He knocked out John,
you've Terrio when Johnny Terrio
was like the PKA champion,
one of the most feared guys and
world cause that point karate and no,
no,
no.
It was PK karate was kickboxing,
but it was above the waist,
like Rick Rufus style and Johnny Terrio.
Is this a,
is that true that he did lose
his son to gang violence?
Yeah.
Johnny Terrio.
Fuck you.
See if you can find blinky Rodriguez.
Kaos Johnny Terrio Antario is t,
h.
E R.
I forget all the rest of
the way to spell his name.
But he was the man and
kickboxing in like the eighties,
cause he was before my time,
he had pretty decent kicks.
Nothing special but
ridiculous knockout power.
And it's supposed to have like boxing.
Boxing.
Yeah.
But blinky Rodriguez caught him
with a left hook and starched him.
And that was always like one of blinky.
Here it is right here.
They're fighting.
This is like one a
blinkies claims to fame.
Throwback.
Yeah.
I mean this is,
which was blinky.
Blinky is the guy in the blue shorts.
Johnny Terrio was the tall,
uh,
Montreal guy.
He was an interesting guy,
man.
He was one of the first
advocates of stair running too.
He was,
yeah,
he was,
uh,
like sprint.
Yeah.
Well running hills and running stairs
because he felt like you felt like for
kicking power.
Good for you,
but fuck them.
Fuck rumbling about gravity.
Oh,
nice.
[inaudible] was a karate guy.
He had all kinds of crazy shit
spinning back fist and all that shit.
But he had this,
oh,
there it is son.
Yo.
He had a ridiculous left stuff.
The arms watching it again.
Boom.
That's beautiful.
One more tall.
Yeah,
from that low kick,
boom,
boom.
That's textbook.
Textbook.
Nothing wrong with a textbook.
So it was an honor just to be there in
blinkies Jay or writing class way later.
I came to La in [inaudible] 93
so it was 93 when I was here.
Dream.
Yeah,
hold the dream where I came
in from Boston to New York,
New York to La.
So I started coming here
around 93 and I think I joined,
I joined the Jetson center,
but they had got damaged from the
earthquake at 93 and the fucking roof,
when it would rain,
it would just flood the whole gym.
So they had a wind up moving shit.
So close.
No word on that fight.
It's a book for the later this year,
which fight?
That Ortiz.
Oh,
later this year.
There's no word.
It's terms when I wonder how
chuck Tito looks as well.
Maybe you see him hitting pads.
He looks good.
Look,
Tito has been winning.
You know he fought recently.
Pete Chell son and recently and Cheetos,
deltoid all Yo,
I saw Tito hip pads.
He still looks good man.
He's still a beast.
He's got a gang of back surgery.
So knee surgeries and back surgeries.
Tito's,
his whole back is all surgery,
man.
There's a crazy video of him.
He's lying unconscious.
They got him sedated and the doctor as
a hammer and a chisel and he's in his
neck and his neck.
Shit.
He's going like this clean clink,
clink clink,
putting some spacer in his neck,
like fusing his neck together.
Shit.
Fuck that.
I'm not about that life too.
That headlock life is a different
life and wrestling cause he's,
he was a wrestler by um,
by trade.
All those wrestlers,
they all wind up with like some
sort of catastrophic back injury.
It's just a matter of how long can
you hold out your Ameena I'm just,
I'm trying to be preemptive
cause something for the
longest time I kind of like
just neglected all that stuff with them.
Like Cairo,
physio.
Well,
no.
So now I'm like,
if I want to fight at
this level and be healthy,
avoid injury,
you got to look after
yourself in that sense.
What kind of strength and
conditioning work do you do?
Strength and conditioning soon.
Zillow is a guy that does my strength
and conditioning work and thing is,
I know not much about these things.
Like even when he tells me to lift,
like put some template,
I never asked what the
numbers are because if I,
if I know what the numbers are,
I feel like I might,
I might get daunted,
I was shit on my car.
I can't lift this.
And then I'll ask afterwards like,
oh,
was that dead lifts with,
Oh,
that was,
uh,
180.
I was like,
okay,
cool.
That's all right.
But um,
yeah,
I do shit like dead lift,
a little bit of bench,
a lot of band work.
Let of plyometrics like exploding.
Yeah.
Learning how to just fire.
Like when he says go,
he has,
he,
he's not just working the muscles.
He wants to work the mind.
So when it's time to explode
the mind just nose move.
Yeah.
I quick twitch.
And how many days a week to do it?
Two Times a week.
And when you do it on,
how do you schedule your,
does the someone schedule all of your
workouts or do you do it yourself?
You have input,
how's that work?
I have input,
but on my main coach teaching Bearman
he's the one that schedules my workout.
So he says,
today we're doing wrestling,
tomorrow we're doing it,
we have a timetable.
So for each camp we'll just
a timetable accordingly.
So for example,
um,
when I go back now I'm not
going to do any vo two Max.
No.
A lack the capacity or that kind of stuff.
No camp stuff I want to go
because it's after the fight.
After the fight.
Yeah.
Skill work yet.
Just upgrade the software
but also cause um,
yeah I think I've,
I've done well this year.
Three,
three fights in six months I'm like,
you know what,
take my foot off the gas a little bit.
I'm just gonna Chill.
How long were you chilled?
40.
Think probably till September may be
born in that time I want to go back to
yoga,
Bikram cause I have,
my flexibility is Kinda,
I felt it in this camp in the early,
it took me a little bit
longer to get my kicks going.
Eugene was teasing me saying
I'm getting old and I was like,
fuck that.
I still have it.
But like I just think I need to get my
flexibility back to where it was when you
do pliers and things along those lines
to you stretch heavily afterwards.
Afterwards.
I should and I try to,
but sometimes it just,
I just neglect the,
I forget,
I forget.
Kind of so important because that's
the time where you really have some
opportunity for stretching,
really advancing your
arrangement metrics really.
Anytime.
Explosive exercise,
you're really tired.
Your muscles are completely
heated up or you know,
becomes great for that too because you
get a lot of exhaustion of the muscles.
Then you have that extreme heat
and everything's super pliable.
When I go to Bikram and I
can still do a full split,
but if I had to do like
a full split right now,
like I know a bit of a struggle.
I felt the way I went
after big from classes,
I was always more loose.
I could like heat is something man.
Yeah,
so we're going to hack it though.
They need to hack it.
Cut The shit.
Of course you can hack it.
If he was between live or die,
never see your family again.
We'll wait 10 more minutes in the sauna.
I shut the fuck up.
I think even just for the first,
for the first session I ever did,
ever a big room,
I sat there.
I didn't push myself as hard,
but I just sat on the Mat.
If maybe that poses a little bit too
much or if I felt some type of way,
but I can handle it.
That ain't bad if you can't look.
The whole thing about it is adaptation.
If you overrun your body right away,
you're not going to recover as well.
You're not gonna enjoy it as much.
If you can't get through a
90 minute beat from class,
but you can do 60 minutes and you have
to sit down for 10 and then jump back in
and just do that.
Exactly.
No,
your body hasn't tell you.
Just sit down.
Just sit down for the first part and
just feel that he just slide what you can
and if you can't do it,
just sit down.
Dude,
that shit is so good for you.
I know.
Be Crumbs.
A crazy ass hall.
I know there's some stories that's crazy.
Did the HBO,
but here's the thing,
man.
Just because he's crazy
doesn't mean it's effective.
You can't throw out the
baby with the bath water.
I know that dude's nuts,
but also,
here's the other thing about beaker,
although he's a great Yogi
and his system is amazing.
I don't even think he
came up with that system.
I think that system has existed for a
long time and it's one of the India or
something,
Google this please.
Uh,
I think he lost a lawsuit based on him
trying to copyright those sequences of
Yoga.
And I think the problem is that the yoga,
those moves,
all those moves have existed for literally
thousands of years to claim them,
well he was trying to crank
claimed them in succession.
So like say if you opened up the style
bender yoga class and you used all be
crumbs moonless that idea,
not bad like it vendors that you want
to meet yoga girls in the back of the
class.
What he's essentially saying is that he
came up with this idea to put them all
in that particular order,
which is a super effective order.
Like kids order of,
of yoga poses is an amazing worldwide.
Yup.
Everywhere you go.
I've taken classes everywhere.
It's all the same.
I only went to one,
so I thought it's the same thing for that.
If you do the,
well there's,
you know,
there's like Vinyasa,
there's flow classes which
are also very interesting.
But I,
and I've taken those two,
but,
um,
there's something really good about
the 90 minute beaker and program.
He just has it nailed.
He figured it out,
but I don't even know
if that was his idea.
I think it was other people that did that.
He sued people or he did?
Yeah,
he's gangster.
He so crazy.
They had this,
uh,
the,
I mean,
I don't even mean in a good way.
They had this HBO documentary
where they're interviewing
him and he was talking
about girls saying that,
uh,
you know,
he,
he banged them and all
this different thing.
He goes,
listen to me.
there are people that would pay $1
million for one drop of my sperm,
$1 million by HBO.
And he's like this one.
Like as if there's a bunch
of people like waiting,
like an auction house filled with
people who wants three houses
right here,
$1 million.
We have $1 million for one drop of sperm.
Who's alway?
How old is he?
What does he look like?
Three drops.
That's what kind of specimen
is he like a old type dude?
Is he in shape?
He,
he's not holding it together the best.
You know,
if you and him,
if he didn't see you,
if you're both the same skin color and
he didn't see your heads and he looked at
your torsos,
you'd know who's who.
Okay.
You know what I'm saying?
Let's put it that way.
I mean,
he's like a seven year old guy.
how long can you still make
sperm one drop of my Instagram?
One minute.
You're like,
yeah,
he's there.
He is.
Oh,
it's a boy.
It's still looking jacked.
Let me see.
Go large on that picture.
Not Bad.
Probably a few.
Too many carbs.
It needs to get some squats
or some hill runs in,
but when it comes to yoga,
he's flexible as fuck and
knows how to do all that.
She doesn't look 70
well you know what man,
look when you t let's go back to
that picture again real quick.
There he does.
Come back to that picture again
real quick in his underwear.
The one in the RF?
Yeah.
Well the one right above that.
Right above that.
Yeah.
Listen man,
look,
just be real gravities
and let's be real as fuck.
If you walk around
wearing underwear like that,
any other class,
you're there to fuck
that guy's dead facts.
Fuck he's there to fuck.
And if you leave a girl alone with him,
he's going to touch her.
He's going to pull that Indian dick out.
He's going to send it home.
He's gonna say like,
what is,
what's an Indian Dick?
As if it was still like a,
just bring it out with the flu day,
like a Cobra.
These weird little taste skivvies
out here.
And if you're a dude and you come in,
you can't be like an amateur yoga.
Oh Gosh,
look at that girl.
Yeah.
Might be.
Okay.
Like you can't have underwear like
dead on and not be good at yoga.
Like if you're like a beginner and you
fall down every time we tried to eagle
pose,
they'll,
they'll talk to you.
Hey man,
why don't you put them more clothes?
But if he walks in there
with his man bucks,
yeah,
he's kind of hard to flex man.
You know what I mean?
Fucking,
it's like,
I dunno if you were a boulder bowling
glove covered with rhinestones.
Like you bet Michael
Jackson gloves though.
Eh?
Well that's the thing.
Someone should do it.
Bullying level where I still was on it.
What else do you do?
Do you ever do gymnastics?
Gymnastics?
No,
I dance.
What kind of debt you said?
You said that earlier.
I forgot to go back to start
off with popping as a kid.
Now I'm crump.
Crump dance.
That's like,
yeah.
What's a crump dance?
Crumped dance is um,
actually were originally in La.
It's a really an expression.
Yeah,
south central La,
like tie dyes and big meal.
Started it off.
But am I remember watching his movie as
a kid and called rise and that's kind of
what introduced to the world.
Kind of like the way Obama did with
[inaudible] made it more mainstream rise
spelled out.
Let's just popping.
This is what pop and Pete,
I'll look up a guy called tide ice.
T I a good look at him.
Go.
Hold on a second.
This shit.
So this guy is from,
from the electric boogaloo.
So this is how I started off.
Look at him.
Go back in the day.
What took the tower though?
Seriously?
Or your hands.
You'll probably use it with a,
with a move or something.
Oh yeah,
he's a man.
It's so strange like that.
People went thousands of
years without these styles.
And then when electronic
music came along people went,
oh that sounds different.
Let's move different.
Yeah.
But for me,
I had this metamorphosis last year or
like around my birthday and then for
whatever reason I just went back to dance
because I felt like I had this damn,
you don't have people get writer's block.
I had dancers block for like
maybe six years or five years.
I just couldn't create,
I could dance like a flow
by couldn't create anything.
Do you know Loma Chenko studied four
years of you kind of Lin classical
Ukrainian,
Ukrainian dance.
One thing I learned is muscle memory.
I know dancers who have to do shows and
they have to learn like 20 different
sequences and that's for the whole show.
Like 20 different.
Each sequence might be like anywhere
from a minute to three minutes and they
have to do it like that.
So when I started dancing again,
when I went back to training,
drilling my,
I can retain that
information so much better.
Like it's muscle memory,
right?
So I don't even have to think
about certain moves when I do it.
It just boom,
because I remember this,
it's easy and the muscle
just doesn't like,
how do you do that?
I wasn't thinking.
So dancing really translates into
muscle memory like that in the,
in the FLS where like dancers
I think have the best,
best muscle memory or maybe
one of the best in the world.
What makes sense that you are,
you're learning to use your
body in a choreographed way?
Almost like a car,
you know,
like stupid.
When I was a kid,
I used to think I really did.
I used to think it was dollar.
They were cool.
They look cool when someone's doing it.
But I hate learning.
I felt like I only learned
them to get the next belt.
But then once I learned them,
I forgot.
I'm totally,
but now that I think back,
I realized like that was a mistake on
my part because when that was was I
thought I knew better,
which is hilarious.
I thought I knew better than people
who learn martial arts for thousands of
years and it's not the Catia makes you
a better fighter but it makes you have
better control of your body.
And the thing about like
holding a kick up in the air,
there's a lot of people
that just can't do that.
I can't actually like that.
But he's,
the guy told me to taekwondo
like literally his dexterity
in his legs heal on
one leg,
pop,
walk,
have you forward and he'll do it.
The other lists like all the way down,
all the way back up
south port or for dogs.
It's a balance.
And I think the balance is
between that and maybe lifestyle,
Thai style.
That's what I'm trying to find.
And sometimes you can go one side too
much but says you have to be objective
enough to say,
this is what I need,
this is how you know
and you feel your body.
You kind of aim for each,
each fight as well.
You know what you want to use.
Like with him.
I wasn't gonna I wasn't gonna throw
some spinning shit at some point.
I did spitting shit.
I say,
Oh,
I met him,
I met him.
Uh,
what's his name?
I was,
uh,
it was after I saw Dana and them.
So I was walking,
walking around with Tony
a shout out to Tony,
Angela.
And then,
um,
I see Jay silver,
who was the guy who used to fight.
He's a thick boy,
like fights,
nothing out of Ruca and he just like
kind of recognize that what's up and they
ain't got me into the club.
And then yeah,
Nick Diaz show us,
Hey,
what's up?
How are you doing?
And I just shook his hand
and I was it and yeah,
he's quick game.
Cool.
Guy's a legend.
He's still fighting.
Well,
he's doing whatever the fuck
Nick Diaz wants to do right now.
It seems like Vegas all the time.
She's only going to fight for,
I think this is just,
I'm going to go out on a limb here.
I think the lack of the UFC
talking Nick Diaz into a fight.
I know he's crazy and
he knows he's crazy too.
That is a criminal criminal
underused of a valued asset.
I think if you wanted to have a
giant paper view right in a big star,
fuck,
he's a huge star,
so it's his brother,
but they haven't fought in forever.
Like Nate hasn't fought since
he lost to Connor and the,
they were going to close for the big,
big money fight,
but probably he made a
ton of money and you know,
he doesn't live a crazy lifestyle and
I believe Nate just got a kid real.
Yeah,
I think,
I think I read that on Google.
See if that's true.
Nate Diaz just had a child.
He,
the way,
congratulations.
He's either,
congratulations,
you had a kid or
congratulations that you did.
I love that dude though.
I love Neda along the way.
They fought their fine.
That Paul daily fine.
I watched the live bro.
I think I sat down for that fight.
You were there live?
No,
no,
no.
I was on the couch while I
was standing up on the couch.
He's crazy shit.
He got clipped too.
He's one of the rare people.
It's got clipped by
Paul Daley and survived.
They come back and then knocked him out
and see the way Paul fell back as well.
Dan stanky leg.
It's almost like his legs
just gave out Austin.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
I keep saying it's easier to knock
someone out when they're tired like that
fight.
Um,
what's a brat?
Had good cardio.
He was able to take it
and I was finding it.
There was one,
I hit him with a body shot,
I think buddy kick and yeah,
he went for a take down straight away.
I pushed,
I pushed him off,
frame them,
got him against the fence or something.
But yeah.
Um,
it's easy to get like some
of these guys you can see,
he never gave me that sign.
Like I'm ready to go.
Like when they are ready to go,
like I want out.
Overwhelming performances of Nick's
career was against frank shamrock.
Frank's all dude.
That was when I was like,
Whoa,
just body shot.
He won't,
but he put his head on
his chest and just bop,
bop,
bop shit to him and frank was like,
really?
You're talking Shit [inaudible] interview?
He was like,
yeah,
I couldn't believe it.
So Ah,
not but honestly like that pace,
even like my first fight,
it's sort of Diaz asking a way
where it's like I didn't do when I,
when I knew he was ready to go,
I just put a steady pace.
Just put your foot on the gas a
little bit but not gas it out.
Just pop,
pop,
find the shot,
find the shop,
find the ship.
There's no need to like it's wasted
energy wise approach to your will to just
your overall and then they gain.
But in particular to your
striking game is that you're,
you're one of those guys that showing
people that you can be very exciting but
take minimal.
There was a couple moments in that fight
where Brad was charging at you where
you're like hub,
hub,
hub.
Here we go.
Side.
Yeah,
100% take the center.
People don't take the center man.
Almost as exciting as watching
someone get knocked down.
I like watching someone figure
out that like hit the right hands,
come in and left hands come behind it.
I'm not there.
Here a queen.
Sweet.
I'll it.
It'll bit in clean sweep if one,
George didn't give one round to him,
but I don't know what's round he gave
cause I thought I had all five rounds
after watching it.
So it was like you can't even 50 45
50 45 and then 49 46 and I was like,
damn,
that would have been cool if it
was just like a 50 45 clean sweep.
Well the most important thing was
not a judge's interpretation of it.
It was the actual performance
and people will enjoy it.
Some people were like young people,
they get caught up in knockouts a lot.
Like,
oh he didn't finish Brad though.
But a lot of people,
the response was,
I'd rather see that than
just a quick finish.
Cause he worked the guy,
he didn't get gassed.
He didn't,
you know,
I didn't,
I didn't dip aisle.
Maybe the third friend of
mine had dipped a little bit,
but I didn't look it.
I have my poker face on and I was fine.
I felt fresh and I even said
after my last fight before that,
like that was based on
the three round camp,
the one I fought in Arizona,
it was based on a three round camp and
I looked in the camera as I can go five
rounds.
I told Eugene McCarthy,
I was like,
man,
I feel I can go another two rounds easily.
And this was based around five rounds.
So after this fight,
honestly I had the reserve rating.
I was like maybe three rounds.
I could've gone if,
if I need it to you.
Do you ever anticipate a time where
people would have more than five rounds at
an MMA fight?
Most of the time anymore.
Most of the time it's totally unnecessary,
but sometimes I,
it was too long.
I was like,
I'm going to get this guy
and like three rounds.
I thought so I felt so I was lazy.
I don't know,
maybe that's just me bigging up myself,
you know,
my own ego.
But yeah,
I just felt like I would take him three,
two or three rounds,
put five rounds and I
still look good doing it.
So I was happy.
Now when you see a guy like Paulo
Costa who has like this just,
I mean he's not totally hittable where
like everything you throw you're going to
hit him.
But he's much more aggressive,
much more than know things.
You see these short arms.
I stood next to him,
I was lucky he ice me.
He's trying to act like
he doesn't know who I am.
And I saw an interview just like,
oh I do not know.
That guy was like,
dude,
what the fuck I am now
that I said after my first fight,
cause these guys want to pretend.
And uh,
I dunno where it comes from.
Maybe because of years
of not getting noticed.
So I'm like,
don't try to act like,
cause a lot of guys,
they'll,
they'll creep from my Instagram and then
like see me in real life and act all
high and mighty.
And I'm,
I'm a nice guy.
I like to be friends,
horse.
I like to hug people.
Say what's up or at least just nod like,
hey,
you know what's up?
I know who you are.
You know I am.
But some people flexed too much.
So for him.
Yeah.
He knows why I'm in this manager.
What's his name?
The fucking Gremlin?
No,
he looks like fucking area or the area.
You don't know what lead Ishmael.
Undertakers guy.
No,
he is.
Well lead is though mixed
martial arts led you fights dude.
He fought in UFC 12 really?
Yeah.
He fired a Takahashi is and who we fight.
Maybe it was 13 c 12 or
13 did he choked out?
Hoists Gracie in a Jujitsu
match in Rio when hoists.
Gracie had just won all the
UFC and he was a fucking man.
Ishmael who was a crossing
Gracie black belt.
Watch this.
He got ahold of hoists and this was in
Brazil and a giant fucking audience.
It was in a soccer stadium.
I think it was a big ass audience
and they wind up going to the ground.
Scoot ahead.
Well you've got him in a clock choke.
And I remember this because at the time,
yeah,
at the time
I was like maybe a maybe a blue belt
and I had tapped the guy with a clock
choke.
I was like
clock jokes and that Shit and he uh,
I remember those at the
g clock chokes with a G.
I try,
I tried it with a little bit.
I can do it when it's all sweaty
but I'm with my arms cause I'm,
I got long arms so I can kind
of get it a little bit if I,
if I tweak it right and
we'll lead had that constant,
we'll eg they used to call him,
he had that constant pressure.
Carlson Gracie top game crushing,
you know,
where are you going to shit out.
Bone fragments have to roll with them.
That was their style man.
Scoot ahead a little bit and you see
will lead gets that clock choke so he can
tell he's the guy that's
like talking for right here,
right here.
He got here and you want
to put noise asleep.
Hoist didn't even cap
went out like a warrior.
Look at that is out.
Fuck out.
Pressure League.
Everybody running out to the mat.
You've got to let it go.
Fuck.
That was what he did to know him.
He was on the cost side number three.
The referee should have
known he I saw him limp.
No you're right.
Shit.
But this was back.
See there's crossing back then this was
when there was like a bit of a rivalry
between Carlson Gracie
and worried about that.
Yeah,
I mean Hickson and hoists
and Heuler and it was,
there was,
she was a bit of a rivalry.
It was out.
He was a beast man.
So now he's managing,
now he's taking care of
fighters and stuff like that.
But he's a real legend.
Well leads a piece to Spec the SPEC.
He's the guy,
he's the guy that I think talks for him.
Paula a lot.
Cause yeah he paused.
I respect him trying to
learn English as well.
That's one of the reasons I was like Ah,
I really want you to ride all the way
cause he was talking all this shit.
Right.
If you wins,
I want to see him and I want to
add the bill up for that fight.
Will be fun cause I,
I will fuck him up.
You felt like there was holes in
your rise came they looked at,
you're saying that it was like,
yeah,
and Paul and Paul's game as well.
There's holes in his game.
Boy.
What did you see in Paulo?
He gets hit easily and you don't want,
you know how you ride with tat?
Tapping Him with a jab.
He doesn't want it.
If I was behind those jabs,
it'd be different setups.
It'd be a different setup.
I can come up with a few
other pathways after that Jab,
like your ride was hitting the jab,
but that's it.
Hit the Japanese chins
up and hit the Japanese.
What do you do after the Jab?
After you landed seven times,
you've got to do something else with it.
You can't just keep jabbing them,
jabbing him if he wants close to had
extreme confidence in his ability to knock
out your room.
He didn't respect this jab.
He will respect my jab.
I look at my knuckle.
So this is my most smokers,
my regular knuckle.
So this one's a little far
and son now that's from him.
What's his name?
It got a little bit
more swollen because of,
um,
Brad to virus.
This is my regular and local and like
I was jabbing him at first pres swollen
right now from the fight a little bit,
but normally it's just cause that's
how it is a triple double knuckle.
That's a triple Chihuahua.
Yeah.
But yeah,
with Brighton,
the beginning of my jab,
he was slipping it and I was like,
all right.
And then you just said drop it down.
And at one point he tried to counter it
like Tyrone Spong slipped the jabbing
count and counter.
But um,
I recognized that.
I was like,
okay,
cool.
Drop it down.
And I hit him with,
I think I went down to the legs and
that took away attention from the top.
Then I was able to go back to the
JAP and not busted him with the Jab.
Now when you're training,
um,
Dee Dee,
do you spend time to work
on traditional moves?
Like we'll kicks and side kicks on the
shit that you throw occasionally or do
you throw them into your overall pad
work game or how do the pad work?
Eugene,
he has his own system and he,
he knows what he,
everyone's different.
So he treats every fight as an individual,
you know what I mean?
So he knows what me,
what he can do on the pads
and what I like to pull.
And if I have an idea like,
oh,
try this out.
He's open.
He's not like he's,
he's,
he's very open man.
He doesn't understand.
He doesn't know.
I'm trying to limit you from what
you can or what you can create.
So all the spinning stuff,
all the creativity of the things
that I kind of bring myself,
I try just to am just walking around
my house shadowboxing sometimes,
you know,
just uh,
my own free time.
I might,
I just think about certain things like
how can I do this different if it's
someone like Chad Mendez,
there's something he does like the,
he fakes the shot an uppercut.
I liked that we're complete
different body types,
but I like that.
And I have my own setups for that just
cause I feel like it's a good move but
with different body types
and he has his own set up.
So I like to create on my own.
And then if I have any ideas or anything
that I feel I can work well with the
pads are with our,
with our flow,
I'll let him know and he's open to it.
Well you're one of these
guys that's coming up right
now that's in this new wave
of MMA fighters that is every,
it seems to me that there's like an
incremental increase in the skill level.
There's always all time greats
like Cain Velasquez and you know,
fill in the blank.
There's like Anderson Silver,
there's these guys that
burst out and they,
they,
they stand out as a extreme performers.
But there seems to me like
right now to be a new witness,
Zap beat mega man's sharp,
sharp off that guy.
There's a few of these guys
that are coming up where
you're watching and you go,
Whoa,
this is some next level you
recognize like a guy like me.
It was seen it for so many years.
I go,
okay,
there's some next level
shit going on right now.
It's like a,
like we're talking about Loma Chenko
like Gloma goes footwork and movement.
This is okay.
This is next level shit.
I've seen a lot.
I mean I'm sure there's
been some all time greats.
When you,
you,
when you go to guys like Pernell
Whitaker and guys like Floyd Mayweather,
you know,
artistic geniuses,
but there's something that Loma Chanko
is doing that they're not doing right.
Hundred percent like it for some things.
I watched his footwork,
I watched the way he looks like,
and you see my fight as well.
I like to look at guys.
I don't just like close my
eyes and hope throwing hope.
I don't throw a note by Ayman fire.
That's one of my quotes.
I say that,
but he does the same thing.
He likes to look and he's
aware of where he is.
He's crunching.
Yeah,
100% chunking,
chunking,
all that inflammation.
Muscle memory.
Like I say,
he's a dancer.
You'd learn what the boys have,
ballet,
all that stuff.
Rhythm,
timing off beat on beat.
It all translates well
into fighting like easily.
Yeah,
it really does.
And it's so fascinating to me and
watching all these like new versions of
different styles like
Khabib in my opinion,
it is a new version of the
ground and pound style.
I watch his ground and pound.
I'm like Jesus fucking Christ.
Like he's such a,
like when he fought Michael Johnson,
there's don't just engage
you fight their son.
This is a Mauler Goddamn mauling he
getting mauled by some crazy alien from
another planet.
I liked the way it traps
the hands and I had,
I had one of them Brad as well,
a little bit,
but I think he recognized
that he tried to go away.
This is when I had his
back for a brief moment,
that five probably about a good
30 seconds and I tapped his hand.
Um,
I learned that from Bjj Scout.
That was on the Ben ask and video.
But Brad wouldn't let
me have his right hand.
I got it though.
Cause like my God,
these fucking monkey fingers like I
can grip the hoc and grip very well.
So hold it and not
pepper them a little bit.
And then that's when I kind of got
to the fence and something happened.
Got a Kamora but I picked
from everyone could be,
there's a way he traps the hands
and we call it the [inaudible].
Everyone.
I,
when I get to my train apart and I
started talking like you would never get
this,
I want to stifle short.
You know,
I just kind of like guys like that just
because they're good at what they do and
if I can get it and make it work for me,
like Bruce Lee make it my own.
I'm really intrigued.
I mean I'm just really bummed out that
Max Holloway had to pull out of that
fight.
Michael Bisping called
them out on that though,
man.
Cause I think most other people
would have just kinda like,
oh well cool,
good luck.
But he called him out on TV light,
Bro.
You look like you just woke up and
you can tell he recognized something.
Cause I heard about it before
I watched the interview.
Then I was like,
oh obviously I didn't look at him.
He's just like,
uh,
you know,
I feel great,
blah blah blah.
Yeah,
facts and he would have fought,
he would've rehydrate it and forth.
Maybe not to the best of his ability,
but he might've got knocked
out and then safety,
sorry,
the punching at night or take is no joke,
no joke.
You know,
and you don't want to come against and
go up against a guy like that and be
slack.
He should go to lightweight or take
is fascinating to me because his,
the way he locks up submissions
is so next level long range.
I like churches that the
technique is so sharp.
Man.
When he dives on Shit,
when he got caught up in that he got them
in a dark at the end of the second of
the first round.
I was like,
what the fuck man,
that is tight like,
but there was something
about the finality to it.
There's like,
this is,
this is not a question of whether
or not we're going to finish it.
Well it was,
it was not that it was this,
the solidity of the technique.
It was like when he locked it in,
there was no doubt this fight was like
the bell rang and then I was like see
some guys slippery.
It's wasn't like maybe
he's going to get out,
you know a guy gets a
good team and it's like,
oh
this wasn't that,
this was death.
Okay.
And then he got him into a gay teen,
jumped on this guard,
jumped in and got them in the GTA.
It's beautiful.
That kind of stuff like I'll take,
I liked the way he looks.
I look at guys like that cause similar
body types and lately I've been catching
that you see in the fifth round gimme
another maybe seven seconds I would
squeeze that.
But the writing on the sweat on the belt,
but every time someone goes for
certain things I can snatch the neck.
But thing is,
I don't have that w the way or take it
has where he knows like okay it's done.
Like for me I'm like,
I think it's tight.
Let me try it.
I know how it is,
right?
If like if you tried to throw a jab hook
with one hand and then throw it with
the other hand,
it just doesn't feel
right with the other hand.
I'm bystanders,
but you know some people from
my own personal experience,
my left hand,
I know how to do it with my left side,
but my right side it feels like awkward.
But there's a squeeze that you develop
a certain guys just get like this
Marcello Garcia style squeeze.
Got It.
I want that.
That's the thing,
cause I know I've got a,
I can catch the neck but there is,
when I catch it I'm not,
I'm not dead set short
like okay it's over now.
Like feed the Hay.
If you don't tap you're going to sleep.
But I want this tab to a
certain amount of black belts.
With that you would
have that feeling right?
He does,
yeah.
He's a beast man.
He's a beast.
He's so fucking explosive on the ground.
He throws up triangles and the bars.
I like his creativity as well.
Yeah,
he thinks outside the box.
Well knocking out Frankie was giant
and hitting them with an upper cut like
that.
Whoa.
I didn't know where.
It's just a,
Frankie can take it to Frankie
fighting at Atlantic city after that.
Uh,
just like a,
yeah,
a few weeks after or four weeks after
that was he fucked cub Swanson a change
his fight to take care of
getting knocked out by Ortega.
Fuck.
What do you think about that?
About guys doing that?
Like getting stock.
Same take time off after that.
I'm not kind of in Brazil,
I took about,
I fought again in July mean you
totally unconscious in that fight.
Yeah,
I remember.
Okay.
So I remember,
this is what happened.
I woke up and was like,
Oh shit,
okay,
let me try and get up.
Fuck.
Moms just felt like noodles or whatever.
And then this kid is
fucking little shithead.
Like a baby came over and just like,
I didn't either yelled at my
face or whatever and I was like,
whatever.
I don't,
and then because it's Brazil,
he'd go crazy.
Like Holy Shit,
he knocked this guy out.
So when then where was
the kid like near you?
By the cake.
He came in the rain and then the referee,
the referee had to like,
Yo everyone get order again.
There was chaos and this is
while they were doing the count.
Yeah.
And then I was trying to get up,
I was trying to get up and then like not,
and I think it was just over after that.
Then I had,
okay,
cool,
good flight.
Give him a,
what do you call it?
Fist pound.
And then the kid again came over next
to me and just laid on the ground.
It's like,
and I thought,
yeah,
I'll stomp his face.
Bother now.
How old was the kid?
Seven.
I don't give a fuck if
you can crawl the can bro.
Shout out to Michael Blackson
but a
broad ties.
Fucking hilarious.
But uh,
yeah.
And then I remember like ruthless.
No,
but then I was like,
it was a dick move,
but at the time and I'll,
yeah,
that was that his kid,
I don't know.
He could go either way.
If your dad don't spank
you or I'll spank you.
That's hilarious.
But then I remember like flashes as well,
walking out.
We usually to steam.
They walked outside,
we just sat there and I was in prison.
I said,
what happened?
And he just told me what happened.
I was like,
all right,
okay.
And then I remember back in the
hotel chilling and then yeah,
I felt like,
fuck,
I'm okay.
This is the worst of
the worst case scenario.
I'm okay.
And that was my first only ever
knock out lost and I was just like,
fine,
that's,
you think you learned something in
that fight about not giving into your
emotions.
And I just don't let people like people,
you're the man,
you ain't shit now I don't give a fuck.
Like I only give a fuck
about those who I care about.
Like someone like ash or Eugene,
those my,
my close people,
if they say something
about me that hurts me,
then I'll give a fuck
boy for someone like,
oh bro,
you're the man,
this that boy you got
to blah blah blah blah,
blah,
or be more this.
I'm like,
cool.
I just smile and wave because I
don't give a fuck what they think.
They are no one to me.
You don't understand.
So yeah,
after that fight I shouldn't,
I shouldn't have given into
people's opinions of myself.
I should have stayed true to me and
just fucked him up in the second round.
I would have knocked them out if I
just didn't literally just right hands.
Why am I only throwing right hand?
So I think that's like a like a
critical lesson in your career.
Facts.
I'm glad it happened.
Like in the,
in the moment know hindsight.
It's like Oh fuck sucks and I hate losing.
I fucking hate losing one thing.
I went 40 and oh before I had my first
loss and that was the assignment markers.
Bahti boys,
cyber,
Marcus like any,
I beat him in that fight as well.
But another judge like
all three rounds of beast,
I beat him all three rounds
and then the extra rent,
a big fight to win extra round.
They made an extra round and the extra,
I still beat him but then they gave it
to him cause he was a superstar at the
time and I realized,
Oh shit,
I lost.
Okay I live my life and that was it.
But I took Winnie for granted for so
long and kickboxing because I was always
expecting to win.
And after that,
after a fire.
Okay,
what's next?
Cool.
I watched the fight maybe twice,
maybe even once,
some time when he wants to
fight and then that's it.
What's next?
But this weekend ever since I go to
the UFC or just before every show,
every single floor after I went out,
cause my,
my brain tries to go to
that place where it's like,
okay what's next?
By like wait,
stop Nigga.
You just main evented in Vegas,
your first flight,
smoke this dude all five rounds and
you're on top of the world right now.
Take this end that's all.
Sit Down and look at the t
mobile arena and just like,
I might've been a little area as well.
You just go myself and then just get
like you get objective and I sit down,
I just like let it sink in.
Like Yo,
you're out here,
you're doing the damn thing
and really embrace it.
And eventually when I go back home and I
let things settle down and I moved back
into the flow of things,
I,
I'll start to get over it.
But the one thing I forgot,
you smell the roses,
just stop sometimes and smell the
roses and it's not called kids,
not,
it's just appreciating what you've done
because you've put a lot of work into
this,
you know?
Yeah.
That's a good attitude man.
I mean I think what you're doing in terms
of your ability to reflect on yourself
and to be really objective
about your abilities,
want to grow your podcast.
The one thing he said when I was at,
cause I don't have any big brothers so
I don't really have anyone Sunday me
apart from Eugene and like,
but sometimes not.
When I first started
listening to you tell,
he's like,
don't be a bitch.
You had this like big rent one time
if you want to do this and do that,
I follow your dreams and like,
you know,
don't be a bitch.
Yeah,
bitch.
Yeah.
Everybody has an inner bitch.
I know.
Tell me about it.
I'm a bitch in the streets for voice.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
yeah,
like it,
part of that was part of the fuel that
helped me amongst a lot of other things.
I take inspiration from everything
to help me like get out of that.
But I remember the date,
September 4th,
2013 I was just like,
Yup,
I'm out.
And I'll never,
I'll never looked.
I never worked a day in my life again.
Beautiful.
Never again.
I couldn't do it.
Uh,
there's one time I don't have to anymore.
You're working,
but you're working at something
you have a passion towards.
You're still like work.
It doesn't feel like work.
That's what I mean.
Like he did.
I don't care if you're
working in the office,
that's your thing.
If you don't feel like you're working
in or you have a passion for what you're
doing,
just do that.
Right.
But then like I said,
some guys who were
fighting and they don't,
they just do it cause it's get,
it gets like Brendan Schaub he was
doing it because he's great at it,
pays the bills.
But now look at it and comedian podcast,
he recognized it though.
He's a wise guy and that he recognized
there was this thing that he just,
did you go back to like his fight
with cro cop or some zero your fights.
He had a different attitude about fighting
and then he realized he didn't have
it anymore but he was still getting paid
well so he didn't know how to jump out.
Exactly.
That's what I mean.
So if you're learning it
doesn't matter what it is,
just opt out.
You helped him though.
You know I listened to that.
I was cringing the whole time.
But you had to.
Yeah.
That's why the guy love that guy.
He's like a brother to me.
And tell him about who was on time.
He wasn't all there.
Yeah.
Terms of like he wasn't all in facts.
That's how all of homes all the time.
Cause a lot of people like they
don't know how to handle it.
Like not the new meat but
the new lifestyle around me.
It's where people get,
they get,
they become like groupies on the in a way
I'm like [inaudible] it's spooky cause
you you don't mean,
but you broke through the membrane
to the neighboring dimension.
You know like Oh shit,
stop vendors on TV.
I get it.
It to people that know you and
then all sudden see you on TV.
That's a mind fuck man.
My first friends get on TV when I was
a comedian and watched him on TV gone,
Whoa,
I kick me out.
I know that guy and I
see him on TV fax that.
But for me,
so the ones that are around me now,
they're the ones that can check me.
Like if I feel up and they can check me.
Like if I fuck up,
like cause I'm not perfect.
I mean it's not a soft no such thing.
Like if I do something and
I'm like I'm in the wrong,
they'll tell him and like,
hey you need to pull your head in.
You know what I mean?
So you need people like that.
Yeah,
I'm glad I have people like that now.
Well,
having people like that and also having
people like Dan Hooker and you camp
having people like all the other
training partners you were talking about,
having great coaches,
all those things have to be together.
It's like you have to have
people that are honest,
that are assessing you.
You have to have a good,
a good trainer who's looking at you,
who knows you.
I was like,
you're a little off today.
Your little slow today or today
we're going to ramp it up.
I think you're hitting the next level.
We're going to add in some
more different things.
Having someone who like to adjust.
And that's after everyone's
different individually,
even with fighting the stuff.
So that's one thing I
love about our staff,
uh,
city kickboxing is because they
can look at someone and be like,
a cool,
he needs to do this.
He needs to work on this better.
He knew,
you know,
and it's,
it's beautiful.
I honestly like 2030 years from now,
I keep telling my team,
it's like they're going to talk
about us the way we talk about that.
But the gym,
like when people talk about in who's Jim?
Whenever you're saying material,
I've met him [inaudible],
Andrea [inaudible] as well in China.
He's a,
he's a kickboxing legend as well.
But yeah,
one day I'll go out there and
get some work work then probably.
Yeah man.
I mean mix it up,
try to like go out.
I love New Zealand,
don't get me wrong.
When I,
when I see the sky tower,
when I hit Oakland,
I get excited like a little
dog when it sees the park.
You know what I mean?
I love being home,
but it's good to get out there,
get some work and without ego.
Cause one thing I realized now
is if I go to a different gym,
it'd be different.
Not because is always like
guy sparring my tribe.
It hurts your,
exactly bro.
Yeah.
We can play,
we can play.
Well I don't get paid for that.
That's the thing.
You were also in one of the
most beautiful countries.
It's ever existed.
There's something about New Zealand,
man.
I said I've never been personally,
but there's a reason why
they filmed the hobbit there.
Cause like you look at some of
that shit and it looks magical.
I,
it feels good to be like,
I just love the vibe.
It's the vibe and using it,
they're like,
what is the vibe?
Like it's chill.
Everyone was real loose.
Like,
and not like loose like Australia,
you can't get loose like that,
but it's relaxed.
That's a different scene.
Loose like Australia and
loose like New Zealand.
All the stress of loose Kahn's
like what's the difference man?
Bam drinks out of a shoe.
Oh yeah.
They don't give a fuck.
He's like the,
the attitude and then their coolest.
Well it can be chill,
but you can get some
real loose comes to that.
I can use it in like in any way.
Like in America,
you know,
but
generically speaking light,
it's just,
yeah,
Australia is a,
depends where he'd go.
Melbourne's in my city,
that's my favorite city in Australia,
Melbourne,
Perth,
and then Adelaide because of my
favorite cities in that order.
But yeah,
I don't know.
I'll probably hit a few
other sports as well.
See what the vibe is like.
Yeah.
What about American gyms?
How many different American gyms,
if you trained that
besides the black ceiling?
Zillions.
Um Hm.
Let me think.
I've trained with a few fighters,
but um,
maybe I've trained with,
let me think.
Well I think that's the
only gym I didn't go to att.
I,
I'm in La.
Did I train?
Most of the Times I'm
here when I'm on holiday,
I don't train I holiday out.
Yeah.
But um,
yeah.
Um,
on the fly,
just train balance,
man.
I tried once in a while
you'd go to too much.
This side you have to find it.
Okay.
Go to the other side.
It never stays right in the middle
for that for a long period of time.
It's just like,
okay,
you're leaning this way,
go this way.
All right.
And to find the balance.
So just feeling and being
honest with yourself.
Objectivity.
I say always check yourself acy
always check yourself no matter what.
How you feeling until I,
if something gets me like maybe if
I see someone makes me feel a way,
like a jealous.
I'm like,
what do I feel that way?
I might want my,
what am I hating?
You know,
like it has nothing to do with me when
I find out where it comes from and then
eventually it's like you identified
the monster and then you,
you slaughter it,
you kill it.
Good for you,
man.
Good for you.
I learned a lot.
I'm coming up.
I'm learning.
You're bad motherfucker.
Listen man,
I appreciate it.
I'm glad we got a chance to do this.
Let's the first one.
First one.
That's why
I get more comfortable
with the way these go on,
dude,
you were great man.
It was fun.
It was fun style bender on Twitter
style bender on Instagram everywhere.
Catch sliding my dms everywhere.